OKAY. FAMILY GET TO USE THE
GAVEL SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RISKS THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND PROVIDED HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BY DISSIPATION
FOR YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR WAS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO I WILL MAINTAIN THE QUORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
WILL BE DISRUPTIVE BUT IF THEY
ARE YOU WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE
YOU CONNECTIONS MUTED WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
HERE IN THE- STREET BUILDING I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWO TWO ZERO ZERO SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. BEGINNER
HEARING TO DO THAT NOW FOR. OF
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY HELP IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THAT
QUOTE UNQUOTE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU AE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR IT
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THIS HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OR IS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
HEARD AFTER. ALL OF OUR
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED BEFORE WE BEGIN NOW OF
LETTUCE ESTABLISH QUORUM- DOCTOR
BACK BILL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR DRAWS OUT HERE RATHER
PRESENT SENATOR CORTEZ THE IN.
WHERE DOES THE PRESIDENT SENATOR
NEWMAN. NEWMAN PRESENT A QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW BEGIN-
WITH ISSUE ONE THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL ITEM ON VISITATION
AND REMOTE COMMUNICATIONS. WE
HAVE- HERE TO MAKE THE
PRESENTATION FROM CDC ARE. C. WE
HAVE SEVERAL I'M NOT SURE WHO'S
GOING TO SPEAK ON THE SPELMAN.
OR MISTER QUELLA. I'M GOOD
MORNING MA'AM OF HIS ACTIONS BY
YOUR MANAGER. MEMBERS MINDS
JENNIFER OKAY ELECTRIC FEMALE
OFFENDER PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
AND MY TEAM AND I OVERSEE ALL
VISITING ACTIVITIES FIFTIES YOUR
RESUME FUNDING TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL DAY OF BUSINESS AT
ALL ADULT INSTITUTIONS AND
INCREASE THE CURRENT
REUNIFICATION TRANSPORTATION BUS
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES VISITORS
AND TRANSPORTATION. TO ALL
INSTITUTIONS. ALL INSTRUCTIONS
OR PER BUSINESS ON FRIDAY. A
OPEN THIRTY. ON AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND SINCE JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND PASSIONATE
PERSONS EVER SHE DOESN'T SOME
FRIENDS. THAT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
VISITS DESPITE SEVERAL WEEKS OF
CLOSURES- TO THE VISITING
PROGRAM DUE TO THE ON THE
GRANDPARENTS. BY PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BUSINESS AS
WELL AS ACCESS TO THE FREE
CALLING AND MESSAGING PROGRAM.
INCREASES SAFETY IN OUR PRISONS
MAINTAINS FAMILY ENCRYPTION AND
COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS PREPARES
CARTRIDGES INDIVIDUALS FOR
SUCCESSFUL RELEASE AND
REHABILITATION. THE STATEWIDE
TRANSPORTATION CONTRACT. HAS NOT
BEEN AWARDED YET DUE TO THE
BIDDERS NOT PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION IDENTIFIED
IN THE CONTRACT. CDCR HAZARD BY
THE SCOPE OF THE WORK AND THE
DOCUMENTS TO RESOLVE THESE
ISSUES AND POSTED A NEW I. F. B.
IN APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WE JUST READ THE CONTRACT BEING
COMPLETED BY THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR. HOWEVER THE
EXISTING CONTRACT WITH FAMILY
EXPRESS CONTINUES TO BE UTILIZED
ON BUSING SERVICES THAT'S J. W.
OUT. OF SOMEONE'S FACILITY
REPUBLICAN BASE STATE PRISON.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE- STRESSED
IN MONTGOMERY WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF ENTERPRISE
INFORMATION SERVICES DISCUSS THE
FREE CALLING AND MESSAGING. I'LL
ALSO BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY. THANK
YOU MISTER QUIVER WITH LINDA
MARIE. MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON MY NAME IS KRISTA
MONTGOMERY AND I'M DIRECTOR OF
ENTERPRISE. INFORMATION SERVICES
AT CDC ARE. WHAT DO YOU KNOW DAY
TODAY ON FREE PHONE CALLS AND
MESSAGES FOR. INDIVIDUALS THE
BUDGET INCLUDES TWELVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
FREE COMMUNICATION OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
CONNECT WITH FAMILIES. OR
FRIENDS VIA TELEPHONE CALLS
ELECTRONIC MESSAGES. THESE
RESOURCES WILL PROVIDE SIXTY
MINUTES OF FREE CALLING TO
CARCERI INDIVIDUALS AND CALL
RECIPIENTS EVERY TWO WEEKS. AND
ALLOW CARCERI PERSONS TO SEND.
SIXTY THREE ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS EACH MONTH. THIS
IS IN ADDITION TO THE FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF FREE CALLING ALREADY
OFFER TO INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS EVERY TWO WEEKS
UNDERCITY SEE OURSELVES AS THE
COMMUNICATIONS CONTRACT. THE
DATE THE GROCERY TO HAVE
UTILIZED THIRTY FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION MINUTES OF CALLING TIME.
AVERAGING APPROXIMATELY FIVE
POINT EIGHT MINUTES PER MONTH.
FOR EXAMPLE IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
APPROXIMATELY NINETY SIX
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
INCARCERATED USED SIX POINT NINE
MILLION MINUTES AN AVERAGE OF
SEVENTY ONE THREE MINUTES OF
CALLING PER CAR STREET
INDIVIDUAL PER MONTH.
ADDITIONALLY INCARCERATED HAVE
SENT ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
MESSAGES AVERAGING APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
MESSAGES. THIS CONCLUDES MY
SUMMARY AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU OF MR
GRUBER ANYBODY ELSE OR IS THAT
CONCLUDE YOUR PRESENTATION. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP NEXT WE
HAVE A PRESENTATION FROM
COALITION ON FAMILY UNITY- I
THINK WE HAVE. OF MUDDY MORE AND
JOHN BUSCAS AND LAYLA AZIZ. I
DON'T KNOW WHICH OF THE OF THE
THREE OF YOU. GOOD MORNING I WAS
START THANK YOU. FOR HAVING ME
MY NAME'S FREE MORE I WORK WITH
THE PLACE FOR GRACE WE WORK WITH
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION ONE OF OUR
PROGRAMS IS CAN'T GREAT TO FIVE
DAY. RT MUSIC BASED PROGRAM
WHERE WE TAKE CHILDREN S. RIGHT
PRESENT TO SPEND TIME WITH THEIR
FATHER WITHOUT THE PRESENCE OF
THEIR CARE GIVER. THIS IS ONLY
DONE AT THREE INSTITUTIONS ONE
OF THE KIDS ONLY SEES A STEP
THROUGH CALGARY'S. AND THAT IS
ONCE A YEAR. BARRICADING THE
STATE PRISON SYSTEM IS
CHALLENGING IN THE BEST OF TIMES
AS OF ONES ARE REGULARLY
TRANSFER TO DIFFERENT PRESENCE
OR HOUSING UNITS WITH DIFFERENT
RULES AND POLICIES BUT TRYING TO
ACCESS INCARCERATED LOVED ONES
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
BRUTAL AND- DEVASTATING
EXPERIENCE THE BUS RIDES THAT
WERE PROMISED THE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. HAVE NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED MANY CHILDREN CANNOT
SEE THEIR PARENTS TO THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF GOING TO
BUSINESS SOMEONE WHO IS
INCARCERATED CHILDREN OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ARE THE
SILENT VICTIMS ON AVERAGE A
FAMILY MEMBER CAN SPEND UP TO
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
ON TWO DAYS OF VISITS IF THEY
ARE VISITING AN INSTITUTION.
WITHIN A COUPLE OF HOURS FROM
THEM THAT NUMBER RISES
SIGNIFICANTLY FOR PRESENCE MUCH
FURTHER. HI BUSES BEEN
IMPLEMENTED MORE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
SEEING THEIR PARENTS. ANOTHER
VERY YEAR IS VISITING
APPLICATIONS. ELIGIBLE PERSON
DISCLOSES THAT THEY HAVE HAD A
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CDC ARE
STILL RUNS THE DOJ. LOCAL COURTS
AND POLICE STATIONS ARE ARE ONLY
REQUIRED BY LAW TO KEEP RECORDS
LONGER THAN SEVEN YEARS THIS
BECOMES AN ISSUE ONCE YOU SEE
OURS DOJ REPORT SHOWS THAT THEY
ARE THAT THERE IS AN ARREST FOR
JAY WALKING IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO AND HIS GRANDMOTHER CANNOT
REMEMBER. THEREFORE CDCR DENIES
THIS PERSON FROM RE APPLYING
RIGHT AWAY AND DOES NOT DISCLOSE
WHY THEY WERE DENIED IT'S
PLAYING A GAME OF GUESS WHAT NO
CLUES ARE GIVEN. THIS HAS GIVEN
. THIS HAS BECOME SERIOUS. ISSUE
WHEN GRANDPARENTS WHO OPTION
OTHER CARE GIVERS FOR OUR
CHILDREN- CANNOT TAKE THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN TO SEE THEIR
PARENTS. THIS COULD ALL BE
AVOIDED OF CDCR DISCLOSED
INFORMATION FOUND ON THE D. O.
AND ASK FOR CLARIFICATION IF
THEY FELT IT WAS NECESSARY. TO
ADD TO THAT IF THEY DID NOT. IF
THEY DID NOT DENY THE APPLICANT
FOR SIX MONTHS AND ALLOW THEM
TO. IMMEDIATELY RE APPLY. IT CAN
OUT FURTHER THIS. ISSUE VISITING
A SUCH AN IMPORTANT FACTOR TO
REHABILITATION HOW CAN CARCERI
PEOPLE BUILD. A STRONG SUPPORT
SYSTEM WITH CDCR IS CONSTANTLY
PUTTING THESE OBSTACLES WHEN
THEY COULD EASILY BE ADDRESSED
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING THE
SECURITY OF THE US TUITION.
FURTHERMORE WE CAN ALL AGREE
HERE THAT MY PRESENCE ON HERE ON
VIDEO SO IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
DESCRIBED AS A VISIT. VIDEO
CALLS ARE NOT VISITS WE DO
APPRECIATE THE ACCESSIBILITY TO
OUR LOVED ONES THAT WAS
SCHEDULED VIDEO CALL. WITH KOBE
WE HAVE ALL LEARNED TO IT AND
ADJUSTED. MOST OF US CAN AGREE
THAT THE DIFFERENCE IT MAKES TO
SEE SOMEONE THROUGH VIDEO AND IN
PERSON IS MUCH DIFFERENT.
JOYCEAN FOLKS FACES WHEN THEY
SEE EACH OTHER IN. PERSON AS
OPPOSED TO A SCREEN. IT IS VERY
BIG. ARCADE WANT TO HELP THEIR
DAD THERE MY THEIR UNCLE OUR
KIDS ASKING WHERE WERE CAN I WHY
CAN I SIT NEXT TO MY DAD WHY CAN
I PLAY JUNGLE HIM WHY CITIES ARE
SAYING THAT WE HAVE THREE VISIT
DATES WHEN I ONLY SEE HIM FOR
TWO DAYS AND THE OTHER ONE IS A
VIDEO CALL IT'S NOT A VISIT WHY
CAN I HOLD MY DAD'S HAND. HELLO
CAN BAY HAS FIGURED IT OUT AND
IS THE ONLY INSTITUTION THAT HAS
THREE IN PERSON VISIT DAYS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY RUNNING VIDEO
CALLS WHY CAN ALL OTHER
INSTITUTIONS THAT THE SAME
SYSTEM IN MOTION WHY CAN- WHY
CAN ALL IT- WE CLEARLY. HOW IT
CAN BE DONE AND I DO NOT SAY
THIS- SO THAT THIS GREAT
OPPORTUNITY CAN BE RIPPED AWAY
FROM PUBLIC IN BASIC FAMILY
MEMBERS. I SAY THIS TO ASK YOU
SEE ARE TO ASK FOLLOW THEIR
INSTITUTIONS TO DO THE SAME. IF
YOU ASK PRESENCE WILL FIGURE IT
OUT. THEY'VE DONE IT BEFORE.
WHEN VISITS HAVE BEEN SHUT DOWN
DUE TO OUR RACE ONLY TWO DAYS OR
SOMETHING BUT INSTEAD OF THE
THREE. THE FUNDS WERE GIVEN TO
HAVE THREE DAYS THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW. FAMILY
REUNIFICATION IS IMPORTANT AND
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR A LOW POINT
FOR INCARCERATED TO HAVE A
STRONG SUPPORT SYSTEM. SO MANY
FAMILIES UNFORTUNATELY HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY DISCONNECTED DUE TO
COPE WITH. MANY MARRIAGES HAVE
ENDED COMMUNICATION ANY
RELATIONSHIP WHETHER
PROFESSIONAL OR PERSONAL IS IT-
COMMUNICATION IS A KEY FACTOR.
THE SYSTEM IN PLACE TO SCHEDULE
VISITS IS NOT WORKING MEMORY
MANY FAMILIES HAVE SWITCH
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
HIGHEST SPEED. IT IS NOT
FRIENDLY FOR FAMILY MEMBERS FOR
NOT TECH SAVVY OR DISABLED. WE
APPRECIATE THE STAGGERING OF
APPOINTMENTS BUT IT IS NOT
ENOUGH WHEN YOU TO SYSTEM IN
PLACE FOR FAMILIES. WHO CANNOT
ACCESS THE INTERNET FOR ELDERLY
AND DISABLED PHONE APPOINTMENTS
THAT WERE USED IN THE PAST ARE
NO LONGER IN PLACE WE NEED TO
STOP CAUSING FURTHER TRAUMA
TOWARD CHILDREN. WE NEED TO
STOP. CAUSING FURTHER
TRAUMATIZED FAMILIES A STRONG
SUPPORT SYSTEM LOWERS RECIDIVISM
RATES WE NEED THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MORE-
ARE OTHERS GOING TO BECAUSE WELL
OKAY- JOHN VASQUEZ. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME. FOR COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE I'M ALSO FOR
MANY PARTS RATED I SERVED OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AS A JUVENILE
LIFER AND HAVE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE ON THE CHALLENGES
FRUSTRATIONS AND HARMFUL
BARRIERS THAT EXIST WITHIN CITY
SEE OURS BIDDING PROCESS I
CURRENTLY SUPPORTS SEVERAL
FAMILIES WITH INCARCERATED LOVED
ONES. WHO TIME AND TIME AGAIN
REPORT DIFFICULTIES OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO VISIT THEIR LOVED ONES
IN PERSON. THESE BARRIERS
INCLUDE LACK OF CONSISTENT
IMITATION OF A THIRD IN PERSON
VISITING DAY LACK OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF TRANSPORTATION
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES UNABLE TO
AFFORD THE HUGE AND BURDENSOME
COSTS OF TRAVELING EXPENSES.
LACK OF VISITING SPACE PROVIDED
BY THE INSTITUTIONS LACK OF
BASIC SCHEDULES PROVIDED BY THE
VSA SYSTEM PUNITIVE DENIALS OF
VISITING DUE TO INVERNAL. OR
INACCURACIES ON A PERSON'S
DATING APPLICATION AND CURATIVE
RESTRICTIONS OR DENIALS OF
INCARCERATED PERSONS ABILITY TO
VISIT DUE TO DISCIPLINARY
SANCTIONS FOR NON VISITING
RELATED INFRACTIONS. THESE
HARMFUL. COURSE VISITING ARE NOT
NEW BUT IN FACT HAVE EXISTED FOR
SEVERAL DECADES PRIMARILY AFTER
THE REPEAL OF VISITING AS A
WRITE IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
DURING THE SO CALLED TOUGH ON
CRIME PARA WHICH HISTORY SHOWS
WAS HARMFUL AND COSTLY TO
SOCIETY AND ONLY LED TO MASS
INCARCERATION. RESEARCHERS SHOWS
THAT IN PERSON VISITING IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
REHABILITATION. AND CHILDREN
SHOULD NOT HAVE UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS TOWARD VISITING THEIR
PARENTS. AS LONG AS VISITING IS
SEEN AS NOTHING MORE THAN A
PRIVILEGE. THESE HARMFUL
BARRIERS WITH VISITING WILL
CONTINUE TO EXIST REGARDLESS OF
HOW MUCH MONEY IS GIVEN TO C. C.
R. TO IMPROVE CONDITIONS CAN
ACCESS TO VISITING. THAT'S WHY
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT IF WE ARE
TO HAVE ANY MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ADDITIONAL
STEPS THAT COULD BE TAKEN TO
IMPROVE THE VISITATION PROCESS
WE MUST ALSO DISCUSS THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THE PROBLEM. WHICH IS
THE DENIAL OF AN INCARCERATED
PERSONS RIGHT TO HAVE A PERSONAL
BUSINESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RESTAURANTS BECAUSE- WE HAVE
NEXT LAYLA AZIZ. YES MY NAME IS
HI YES MY NAME IS LEILA AZIZ I
LIVE IN SAN DIEGO I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF PILLARS OF THE
COMMUNITY AND ALSO A RE ENTRY
AND RESPONSIBLE FATHER
FATHERHOOD EXPERT FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. AFTER WORKING
SIXTY HOURS A WEEK DEALING WITH
HOMEWORK AND EXTACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES YOU WAKE UP AT FIVE
THIRTY AM. YOU POUR YOURSELF A
CUP OF COFFEE YOU MAKE SURE YOUR
INTERNET CONNECTION IS SECURE
YOU MAKE SURE NOTHING ELSE IN
YOUR HOME IS USING A WIFI
CONNECTION. AT FIVE FIFTY YOU
BEGIN TO LOG IN. YOU PRACTICE
GOING TO THE CORRECT PAGE AS
FAST AS YOU CAN YOU MAKE SURE NO
OTHER APPLIANCE IN THE HOME IS
USING WIFI. AT FIVE FIFTY NINE
AM YOU BEGIN YOUR COUNTDOWN. YOU
SET YOUR PHONE TO SIXTY SECONDS
YOU LOG IN AND NAVIGATE TO THE
RIGHT PAGE BEFORE YOU SOLIDIFY
THE BASE STATE YOU'RE SHAKING.
YOUR BREATHING HARD YOUR BRAIN
AS SOON AS YOUR TIME IS A FIFTY
EIGHT SECONDS YOU BEGIN
NAVIGATING TO THE NEXT PAGE YOU
PICK YOUR TOP YOU SELECT THE
AGREE BUTTON WHEN YOU PRESS
CONFIRM BASED SYSTEM SLOWS DOWN.
AND BEGINS CLOCKING YOUR BROWSER
SHOWS THAT SOMETHING IS LOADING
BUT LOTUS FLOWER. IF YOU DO THIS
PERFECTLY. YOU HAVE AN 80%
CHANCE OF GETTING A BUSY. IF YOU
ARE ALL IF YOU WERE DISABLED IF
YOU ARE NOT MOVING AT THE SPEED
OF SOUND IF YOU MAKE ONE MISTAKE
IF YOU FAIL TO CHECK OFF ONE.
BOX IF YOU MISS ONE SECOND YOU
WILL NOT GET A VISIT. I LEARNED
THIS THE HARD WAY AFTER WAKING
UP THREE MONTHS. AND NOT GIVING
A VISIT. MY NAME IS LAYLA IS THE
ON THE WAY OF AN- PERSON. I LIVE
IN SAN DIEGO CA. MY HUSBAND IS.
AT HIGH DOES STATE PRISON FIVE
HUNDRED IS. EIGHT MILE AWAY. OUR
STORY IS SIMILAR TO MANY OTHER
PRISON DOWN. I COLLEGE PRISON
FAMILIES BECAUSE DECISION CDCR
MAKES DIRECTLY IMPACTS. OUR
CHILDREN AS WE FIGHT WITH EVERY
BONE. IN OUR BODY TO KEEP OUR
FAMILIES TOGETHER. MY TWIN BOYS
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THEIR
DAD. ALTHOUGH THEY ARE VERY WELL
BEHAVED AT SCHOOL THEY STRUGGLE
WITH READING. DURING VISITS MY
HUSBAND WORKS WITH THE BALL ONE
ON ONE. CREASED A LETTER C.
SKILLS THEY LOVE HIM. THEIR
EAGER TO PLEASE AND I ALWAYS
RISE TO THE CHALLENGE. THEY LOVE
THE INTENTION EVEN IF IT'S
DURING THAT LEAST FAVORITE
SUBJECT. THE RESEARCH ON
CHILDREN MAINTAIN PHYSICAL
CONTACT WITH THEIR- INCARCERATED
PARENTS IS SCARCE. WHAT I HAVE
SEEN TWO IF NOT PLEASE IN
QUALITATIVE EXPERIENCES IS THAT
CHILDREN WHO MAINTAIN A PHYSICAL
CONNECTION. WITH THEIR PARENTS
DO BETTER IN SCHOOL. HAVE BETTER
BEHAVIOR HAVE A BETTER SELF
ESTEEM AND UP WITH A HIGHER
LEVEL OF EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
FOR EXAMPLE THE POLICY INSTITUTE
JUST HIRED A NEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR ERIC. WAS THE CHILD OF
A FORMERLY INCARCERATED PERSONS
ERIC'S MOTHER DID HER BEST TO
ENSURE HER SON HAD PHYSICAL
CONTACT. WITH HIS FATHER. HER
SON IS ENROLLED IN BERKLEE FORCE
MASTER'S DEGREE AND IS LEADING
ONE OF THE STRONGEST
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
NEED TO EXPAND IN PERSON
BUSINESS AT LEAST THREE DAYS A
WEEK. AND BELIEVE THE VISITING
TO AT LEAST THREE DAYS A WEEK.
IF WE KNOW A PRACTICE OF KEEPING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES APART. IS
AN AWFUL PRACTICE WHICH HARMS
CHILDREN. WHY WOULD WE MAINTAIN
. THE FAMILIES ARE STILL WORK
AND WORK DURING THE WEEK STRUCK
BY US. YES SAFETY. IN RETURN
THEY DON'T HAVE THE BILL TO SEE
THE LOVED ONE. CHILDREN DESERVE
JUST TIME WITH THEIR PARENTS.
CDCR TEAMS TO SEND A CARD WITH
PEOPLE FAR AWAY FROM THE LOVED
ONES. MY HUSBAND'S DIED SHE FOR
HER. MY TO BE UP. I COST MY
FAMILY NINE HUNDRED TO FLY TO
READ OUT IN THE- TO SUSAN CA.
WHERE HIGH DESERT. IF WE DRIVE
ACROSS WORKING DOLLARS. A
TYPICAL DRIVERS TWELVE HOURS
AFTER GAS AND STOP. OUR HOTEL
ROOM THERE ARE NO. IS A HUNDRED.
FOR THE WEEKEND. WE SPEND AT
LEAST NINETY DOLLARS IN THE BEEN
THE MACHINE DURING ALL DAY
VISIT. THERE'S AN AVERAGE OF
SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT'S AN
AVERAGE OF SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS. PER VISIT EVERYTHING
GOES WELL. YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SPECIAL BROCK. HAS TO BE DONE A
CERTAIN WAY IN A CLOSE UP TO FIT
A CERTAIN WAY. THESE ADJUSTMENTS
CAN USUALLY OUT ON TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR EVERY VISIT. THANK
EVERYTHING IS PERFECT A FAMILY
NORMALLY FROM POOR WORKING CLASS
ENVIRONMENTS WILL ONLY SEE THEIR
LOVED ONE WAS PER MONTH WILL
SPEND. 800-800-0400 ANNUALLY. A
FIVE YEAR SENTENCE WILL EQUAL
FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS. THIS
AMOUNT EQUALS AN EXCELLENT
CONTRIBUTION TO YOUR FOUR OH ONE
K. PLAN UP OR DOWN PAYMENT ON A
WHOLE. WE WILL NEVER SEE THIS
INVESTMENT. WE FIGHT TO MAKE
SURE CHILDREN ARE NEVER HOUSE
BEHIND THESE WALLS WE LIMIT
THEIR ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND TRAUMA. WE GIVE
THEM NORMAL IN THE MOST ABNORMAL
PLACE WE KNOW THAT LEAVING OUR
CHILDREN IN THE CARE OF OTHERS
IS THE OPPOSITE OF SAFETY. IT
WOULD BE CHEAPER BUT COULD COST
AMERICAN AFFECTS. THE PRISON
VISITATION ROOM IS ONE OF THE
SAFEST PLACES IN THE WORLD. IT
IS SAFER THAN A LIBRARY IT IS
SAFER THAN A CONCERT IT IS EVEN
SAFER THAN A CHURCH RESEARCH THE
DATA. THERE ARE NO INCIDENTS OF
VIOLENCE EVEN ARGUING IN A
PRISON VISITING ROOM. LATELY
HIGH DESERT STATE PRESIDENT ONLY
BEEN OFFERING. WATER TO VISIT-
SITTING IN A BUSY ROOM FIRST.
HOURS LOCKED IN. WITH NOTHING TO
EAT. IF WE WERE TRULY A- TO MAY.
FAMILIES THE PERSON WOULD HAVE A
BEEN DIFFICULT. FRESH FOOD WITH
. COULD PAY. TOGETHER THEY WOULD
BE ABLE PLAY A- ON THE- FOR
THESE THREE. TO GET FOR AIR. OF
CHILDREN. VISITING HIS. WORLD
FOR STEP OUR- OR FOR SPARE. OF
HUNDREDS DOLLARS TO LEAVE EARLY
FOR FOOD. IS AN- PROCESS BUILDER
TOXIC IF TALKS. IS TOXICITY. IN
THE BODY OF. YOU COGNITIVELY.
PHYSICALLY AND- INSTEAD CDCR
SMALL CHILDREN TO SIT ALL. HOURS
WITH ONLY WATER. IF YOU WERE
MAMA. YOU KNOW THAT HEARING
MOMMY I'M HUNGRY. TWENTY TIMES
AS A STEP. ON WATER IT'S
HEARTBREAKING. I THE ARMATURE
REMOVE OF VISIT BASED ON ISSUES
THAT HAVE NOTHING TO WITH. HARM
OUR- I CHILD SENIOR PARA SHOULD
NEVER BE SEEN AS A LUXURY. IT IS
A MESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH MISS AZIZ- WHEN I
TRY TO LOG ON TO MY COMPUTER ON
MY LAPTOP I'M SCARED TO DEATH
I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO. GET
THROUGH OR I'M GOING TO BE
DROPPED I'M GOING TO PUSH THE
WRONG BUTTON SO. I HAVE A TINY
IDEA OF WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON NOW AND- OPEN THE
QUESTIONS TO MEMBERS OF THE OF
THE COMMITTEE SENATORS. CENTER
CORTESE- TH THANK YOU MANAGER A
YES SIR ON THIS TOPIC IN FACULTY
ASSUME SEGUE FROM THE LATEST
COMMENTS IN THE IN THE PER ONCE-
SO IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE CHEER I
WANTED TO SHARE SOMETHING- THAT
MY WIFE- SENT ME A BULLET POINTS
WILL TAKE A MINUTE- SHE HAPPENS
TO BE- HE A MENTOR- FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS NOW. HE INCLUDING
FOLKS IN THE JAIL AND PRISON
SYSTEM- AND SHE JUST SO HAPPENED
TO BE COMPLAINING TO ME A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE-
TRYING TO. COMPLETE IF YOU WILL-
VISIT- AN ONLINE VISIT A VIDEO
VISIT AS SHE CALLS IT SO IT IS
AGAIN JUST TAKE A SECOND YES-
AND I THINK IT VALIDATES SOME OF
WHAT WE JUST HEARD SO MAYBE
THERE'S SOME VALUE THERE- THE
CURRENT PRICE THIS IS. I'M
STARTING NOW. THE CURRENT
PROCESS TO SIGN UP FOR A VIDEO
VISIT IS. LOG IN AT SIX TWENTY
NINE AM. EXACTLY SIX TWENTY NINE
NOT SIX TWENTY EIGHT OR SIX
THIRTY- SIX TWENTY NINE AM ON
SATURDAY MORNING FOR VISITS THE
FOLLOWING SUNDAY. VISITS CANNOT
BE SCHEDULED EARLIER IN THE SIX
THIRTY AM SATURDAY. SELECT THE
NAME OF THE INMATE TO INMATE TO
VISIT HIM PRESS QUOTE SCHEDULE
VISIT BUTTON AT SIX THIRTY
PRECISELY. IF TOO EARLY. I GET A
MESSAGE SAYING VISITS CANNOT BE
SCHEDULED UNTIL SIX THIRTY IF
I'M EVEN A FEW SECONDS LATE THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM CRASHES FOR ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES AFTER THAT. IN
PERSON VISITS ARE AVAILABLE BUT
NOT VIDEO BUSINESS SO THEN I
HAVE TO WAIT ENTER WEEK TO TRY
AGAIN. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
VIDEO VISITS THEY ALLOW BUT IT'S
CURRENTLY NOT ENOUGH- SO I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THAT. YEAH IT'S
SORT OF INDIRECT TESTIMONY YOU
CAN TAKE THAT AS- FOR AGAIN FULL
DISCLOSURE- AS MY WIFE OF PADDY
CORTEZ WHO SHARE THOSE COMMENTS
BUT- OVER THE COMMITTEE WILL
RECEIVE THAT AS- CONSTITUENT. A
TESTIMONY- BECAUSE SHE DID JUST
EMAIL ME THIS THIS MORNING-
KNOWING THAT WE WOULD BE IN THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING WONDERSHARE
THEN IT ALSO AT SOME POINT LIKE
TO HEAR. A RESPONSE TO THAT
WHOLE. HOW IS IT CONSIDERED TO
BE APPROPRIATE ACCESS OF COURSE
ISN'T WHAT WE NEED TO DO- IT TO
MOVE TO A MORE ACCESSIBLE
SYSTEM. WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
WITH THIRD NEWMAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO NOW ARE YOU WE WANT TO
HEAR. A RESPONSE YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD. OKAY IF YOU DON'T MIND GO
HEAD I THINK IT'S ALL CONNECTED
RIGHT SO OKAY- YOU KNOW TO LAY
LOW AS CALM AS HE WITH THAT'S-
EIGHT YOU KNOW INHUMANE IS THE
ONLY WAY I CAN THINK OF AN
ANSWER NOT NOTHING IS PERFECT
UNDERSTAND THIS STRETCH DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE SET UP NEW
SYSTEMS- BUT CLEARLY YOU KNOW IF
THAT'S THE LIFT THE LIMITING
FACTOR IS TECHNOLOGY SOMEBODY
HAS RESPONSIBILITY TO. FIX THAT-
THE THING I'M I'M I'M I ACTUALLY
LIKE TO TOUCH ON ALSO IS. PHONE
CALLS RIGHT IMMEDIATE THE SO.
NOT REALLY CLEAR WHY. LET ME
START SO YOU KNOW TECHNOLOGY IS
HARDER TO BILLS SYSTEMS BUT
CERTAIN TECHNOLOGIES ARE TOTALLY
MATURE. AND PHONE CALLS
OFFICIALLY FREE ALRIGHT SO IT SO
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME THAT
WE'RE STILL RATIONING. TIME YOU
KNOW VIA VOICE ON THE PHONE-
BECAUSE IT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A
COMMODITY THAT. COST ANYTHING-
AND IT'S CERTAINLY YOU KNOW YOU
COULD PROVIDE MORE AND FULLY
ENRICH THE LIVES NOT ONLY
INMATES BUT THEIR FAMILIES- IN
WAYS THAT. MIGHT TAKE SOME THE
PRESSURE OF. THESE OTHER SYSTEMS
SO- YOU KNOW I'D LOVE TO HEAR AN
ANSWER AT A IF THERE ARE.
OBSERVE BUDGETARY NEEDS WE NEED
TO. I THINK IT'S CLEAR THIS
COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN DRESS THEM.
BUT IT SHOULD BE IT'S NOT- OKAY
TO DILLY DALLY RIGHT I MEAN YOU
KNOW THE PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
HOUSE NOW- AND THAT IS JUST A-
SHOCKING SITUATION THAT THE YOU
KNOW THE- YOU'VE GOT A FIVE
SECOND. INTERVAL AT THE
DETERMINES WHETHER YOUR SON CAN
CONNECT WITH HIS FATHER- THEN WE
SHOULD ALLOW THAT NIGHT THAT LED
TO HEAR ANSWERS TO HOW WE FIX IT
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO LET'S
GO BACK TO- CDC ARE ND- MR CLUB
I DON'T KNOW WHO WILL WANT TO
ANSWER. EACH OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN ASKED BY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CHRIS
MONTGOMERY AYE AYES AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE- THIS
INFORMATION SERVICES I CAN
ANSWER SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
WITH REGARDS TO THE VIDEO OUR
SCHEDULING. APPLICATION I
UNDERSTAND THIS HAS BEEN
FRUSTRATING FOR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY WHEN WE FIRST IMPLEMENTED
IT THERE WERE PERFORMANCE
ISSUES- THAT WE WORK WITH OUR
VENDOR TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN.
FIX THOSE- ON PERFORMANCE
ISSUES- AND THAT WAS IT EARLY IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE- WE ALSO
HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH AND MAKE COUNCIL THAT WE-
EIGHT LIVE IN MAY COUNCIL TO GET
THEIR FEEDBACK. IMPROVE THE
APPLICATION. OF ONE OF THE
SUGGESTION WAS OFFER STAGGER
SCHEDULING NOW WHICH WE HAVE
WOMEN IN DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE- WE DIVIDE THE
INSTITUTIONS BETWEEN NORTHERN.
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN- WE START
TIMES OF. SIX SIX THREE AND SUB.
I SUGGESTION WAS TO BUY MINIMUM
. WHERE PEOPLE ARE VISITS- THERE
WAS DISCUSSION THEY TRY TO A
VISIT AND THEN THEY WOULD IT
WOULD JUST STOP AND LIKE- AND AS
YOU HEARD. PROBABLY CROSS OR IT
JUST DIDN'T SEE MY ANYTHING
HAPPENING. ARE WE READY TO
PROVIDE BETTER MESSAGING THAT
SAYS YOU KNOW THE BUSINESS FULL
OR YOU KNOW YOU TO TRY A
DIFFERENT TIME. THIS WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
AGAIN WE CAN TO WITH STATE WHY
IN MAY COUNCIL FOR SUGGESTIONS
AND IMPROVE. AND WILL CONTINUE.
TRY TO IMPROVE THE APPLICATION.
BEFORE. AND IF YOU COULD MISS
FUND CONDUCTED IF YOU ON VOICE
ON VOICE COMMUNICATIONS AND SO
THE UNDERSTAND YOUR WRITING
YOU'RE RUNNING AN ENTERPRISE.
DEPARTMENT BUT DO YOU KNOW WHY
WOULDN'T VOICE WE SHOW THAT
STATES FREE AT WHATEVER LEVEL
YOU KNOW AGAIN. CONSISTENT WITH
YOU KNOW IN MAY SCHEDULES BUT
WOULD WHAT WHY WOULD BE LIMITED
TO IT TO SOME INCREMENT. AGAIN-
THE VOICE WHICH IS I'M ASSUMING
YOUR PHONE CALLS AS AS I
DISCUSSED WE ARE OFFERING- FREE
FARM CALLING AND THAT'S UP TO.
SIXTY MINUTES EVERY TWO WEEKS SO
WE DO OFFER FREE CALLING FROM
CALLING TO OUR BUT BUT WHY WHY
ONLY SIXTY MINUTES AT THIS POINT
. OUR BODIES WE RISK FROM
FUNDING FROM THE BUDGET ACT TO
COST AND SO IF YOU COULD YOU
JUST CLARIFY LOOK WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE INCREMENTAL COSTS
THAT YOU INCUR. BY IF YOU ADDED
MORE MINUTES THAT THAT'S THE
THING THAT PUZZLES ME ABOUT
ABOUT BACK ON QUITE VOICE
PROPERTY PHONE CALLS- AGAIN THE
COST PER PHONE CALL IS. THERE A
FULL RATES ARE TWO POINT FIVE
CENTS PER MINUTE. IS WHAT THE
COST IS THE UNIT COSTS SO- I
DON'T HAVE THE LIKE THE
INCREMENTAL THAT YOU JUST ASKED
ME I'D HAVE TO DO THE MATH. AND
THAT TOO BUT FOR SAYS IT'S BASED
ON WHAT EXISTING CONTRACT WITH
THE VENDOR YES YES IT'S AN
EXISTING CONTRACT WITH FIVE
POCKET COLLEGES I GUESS I'D I'D
SUGGEST LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVE
VENDORS WE COULD GET. MORE FOR
YOUR MONEY BUT- I'M SURE YOU'RE
DOING THAT THANK YOU. PLEASE YES
PLEASE. THANK THANK ABOUT YOUR-
OWN THEY JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
FOR THE RECORD THAT THE REPORT
THAT I JUST READ IN. OF FROM
PATTY CORTEZ HE WAS THIS MONTH
SO- I HEARD LISTEN VERY
CAREFULLY AS TO. THE ATTEMPTED
CORRECTIVE MEASURES HAVE BEEN
TAKEN OF GOING BACK IT SOUNDS
LIKE WELL INTO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO MAYBE EVEN TWENTY TWENTY BUT-
THESE ARE EXPERIENCES THE LAST
TWO SATURDAYS. OF THIS MONTH
PRIOR TO. TO THIS WEEK SO- IF
THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THINGS
ARE FIXED ALTHOUGH I HAVE TO
CREDIT WITH YOU. WITH BEING VERY
CANDID SAYING STEGER SCHEDULING
SPIN ATTEMPTED- THE RESPONSE TO
CRASHES. HAS BEEN BETTER
MESSAGING THAT. APPARENTLY THAT
THE SYSTEM'S CRASHED IN YOU NEED
TO TRY. NEXT WEEK WHICH I DON'T
THINK SUCCESSFUL GOING BACK TO
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES COMEDY
COMMENTS. MEANS BEYOND
UNACCEPTABLE- YOU SEE THAT YOU
KNOW. THE CDC ARE THAT YOU'RE
CONTINUING TO ME TO TRY TO DEAL
WITH IT BUT- I THINK THE URGENCY
THAT I'M SENSING RIGHT NOW IS
THAT WE NEED TO BRING SOMEBODY
ELSE IN- YOU KNOW TO ASSIST WITH
THAT BE AN AUDIT. OR- THE L. A.
O. OR OR SOME OTHER. A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY CAN GET
RIGHT TO THE PROBLEM I THINK
THIS ONE THE SITUATIONS WHERE-
THE GOOD PERSONAL FRIEND OF
MINE. WHO IS INVOLVED IN A
DIFFERENT- A DIFFERENT SECTOR
SAYS. WE HAVE A SITUATION LIKE
THIS GOAL RIGHT TO THE KERR.
IMAGES YOU JUST NEED TO GO RIGHT
TO THE CURE OR WEEK. IT'LL IT
WITH PEOPLE'S RIGHTS ARE AT
STAKE IN THESE KIND OF- ACCESS
PROBLEMS OR OR ISSUE I THINK-
YOU KNOW EVEN EVEN THE
SUGGESTIONS OF AUDIT IN AN
OUTSIDE ASSISTANCE SMACK OF
FURTHER ANALYSIS RATHER THAN
JUST. ON FIXING THE PROBLEM IS
CENTER NEW INTEREST SAID- SO
THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS I REALIZE
IT DOESN'T. AND THIS IS AN
ACTION. ITEM TODAY BUT- YOU KNOW
I I'M I'M JUST GONNA TO FURTHER
DEVELOP THOSE THOUGHTS I GUESS
BASED ON WHAT I HEARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR- ANY- DO
YOU HAVE ANY- MISSLING GO MARIE
DO YOU HAVE ANY. RESPONSE TO
WHAT. SENATOR CORTEZ HE JUST
RAISED. WE WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT THAT- AGAIN WHAT WILL WORK
WITH OUR VENDOR ON IF THEY'RE
SEEING THESE ISSUES OF CRASHES
AND THAT TYPE OF THING- IT'S- I
HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT THAT WILL
CERTAINLY LOOK INTO IT. SO IF I
COULD JUST ADD A FEW MORE
THINGS- THE THREE DAYS OF IN
PERSON VISITING WHICH SEEM TO BE
THE MOST IMPORTANT THAT
EVERYBODY HAS TESTIFIED TO IN
PERSON. IS THE- PREFERENCE THAT
FAMILIES HAVE FOR THE CHILDREN
BEING ABLE TO VISIT PARENTS OR-
IS THAT AT ALL INSTITUTIONS
RIGHT NOW OF A THREE DAYS OF IN
PERSON VISITING- AND IF NOT WHY
NOT AND WHAT IS THE TIMELINE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. ALSO MET MANAGER
PERFORMANCE- ARE NOT THREE DAYS
OF IN PERSON YEAH. WE GOT GETS
USED. OF THE OPTIONS THERE SOME
BAND WITH THE- THAT WE STRUGGLE
WITH OUR TO DO. THIS THING
DURING- WE WITH- FOR TENNIS. ARE. IT'S NOT IN PERSON IS IN APT
WELL ALL OF OUR ANSWERS TO IT
CAN YOU TELL ME WHICH INSTEAD
THERE ARE THREE D. OF A PERSON.
OKAY SOMEONE. SO AT CERTAIN AND
I DON'T THE EXACT ONES. BUT
THERE ARE WHEN THERE'S BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WAS- UP. SMALL
HOME OF THIS NUMBER ORDER- THIS
ONLINE. BIG DEAL OUT OF TO HAVE
. UNTIL TEND TO BE YOUR ABOUT
THANKS TO. OKAY THIS IS NOT
QUITE A- QUITE A OF A VERY
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION- ISN'T
CAN MISS MONTGOMERY SHOULD HE
DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THAT PROGRAM. RIGHT. I CAN
ANSWER ANY VIDEO IF YOU ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE VIDEO
CURSING OKAY OKAY I'M THRILLED
DAYS OF IN PERSON WOULD BE. YEAH
I MEAN ISN'T THAT THAT THREE
DAYS OF IN PERSON VISITING ISN'T
THAT- THE REQUIREMENT OR THE
GOAL RIGHT NOW. SO IN DISCUSSION
WITH OUR YOU KNOW I ISSUE MY IT
SEEMS TO HAVE- IN THE LOCAL IT
SEEMS VIDEO BUSINESS HAVE BEEN
REALLY POPULAR- IN SO TO A POINT
WHERE FOLKS. CAN GET HOME WE CAN
TALK WITH THEIR LOVED ONES CHAU
THINGS ARE GOING ON HOMES. VIDEO
MISSING HAVE BEEN REALLY
SUCCESSFUL. AND SO. IN THE VIDEO
VISITS ARE. IN THE- AND SO
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF SPACE TO
OVER THE SAME TIME. OKAY BUT THE
END OF A SUCCESSFUL AND I
CONGRATULATE IF THERE'S A
SUCCESSFUL. VIDEO VISITING-
PROGRAM BUT IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY
THE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
THAT THREE DAYS IF THAT IS THAT
THREE DAYS- OF IN PERSON
VISITING IS THAT PER. MONTH OR
HOW HOW OFTEN IS THAT SUPPOSED
TO BE- WEEK. SO THIS WAS TO BE
THREE DAYS OF IN PERSON VISITING
PER WEEK- AND WE'RE NOT THERE
YET AND- WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WHICH INSTITUTIONS THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE. I WAS TOLD
THAT IT'S JUST ABOUT.
CHRISTENSEN THAT'S THE ONLY
PRISON THAT IS PROVIDING THE
THREE AYS PER WEEK VISIT YES.
OKAY AND DO YOU KNOW WHY OR CAN
YOU EXPLAIN AGAIN WHY IS IT NOT
TAKING PLACE AT THE OTHER
PRISONS. SO AND WITH ISSUES ARE
CURRENTLY S. R. INSTITUTIONS
DON'T HAVE BACK ISSUES HI AM NOT
A NINETEEN VOTE I'M PERSONS ARE
AT AS FAR AS WHAT'S- AND DURING
THE WEEK DAYS OUR SEARCH. I'M
SORRY YOU'LL HAVE TO REFER TO
WHO. MY COLLEAGUE CHRISTMAS AND
WHICH OKAY MISS MONTGOMERY. SO
THE QUESTION THAT I'M HEARING IS
THE THREE DAY IN PERSON VISITING
VERSUS VIDEO VISITING- NOT NOT
NOT VERSES BUT OKAY IN ADDITION
IN ADDITION THIS IS THIS IS WHAT
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE THREE DAYS OF IN
PERSON VISITING. PROVIDED OKAY-
SO. AGAIN THAT'S NOT MY PROGRAM
I YOU KNOW AFTER. REFER TO TODAY
ON- IF YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THE
THREE DAYS OF IN PERSON
VISITING- AND NOT THE VIDEO
VISITING. IT FOR IMPLEMENTING
MATTER IF IT'S MAINLY BECAUSE OF
OUR WE'RE SHARING THE ROOMS
BETWEEN. AND I APOLOGIZE AND SO
I THOUGHT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
MORE VIDEO VISITING AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR IT SO THE REASON
THE REASON IS THAT WE USE THE
SAME AREAS SO WE'RE VIDEO
VISITING WERE ALSO USING- THAT
IS OCCURS IN THE SAME ROOM AS
THE- IN PERSON BUSINESS. AND SO
IT TAKES THE COMPUTERS AND ALL
THAT STUFF TAKES UP SPACE- FOR
US TO CONDUCT IN PERSON MEETING
WITH A VISITING. OKAY WELL. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO SUBSTITUTE I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY MAY BE
MORE CONVENIENT FOR SOME BUT
FROM THE TESTIMONY THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN AND WHAT WE'VE OF
COMMUNICATIONS THAT WE RECEIVED
THIS IS NOT THE IN PERSON
VISITING IS NOT OR THE REMOTE
VIDEO REMOTE IS NOT A SUBSTITUTE
FOR THE IN PERSON AND SO I THINK
WE KEEP I KEEP HEARING FROM YOU
IS HOW SUCCESSFUL THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING- VIDEO VISITING IN
BUT IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO
SUBSTITUTE- AND THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT WE SET UP FOR- OVERSIGHT
TODAY. AND I REALLY EXPECTED OF
THE RESPONSES TO BE MUCH MORE
COMPLETE THAN WHAT WE'RE
GETTING- WITH REGARDS TO
TRANSPORTATION- ARE ALL THE
INSTITUTIONS OFFERING
TRANSPORTATION. ALL THE ONES
THAT ARE ARE CURRENTLY OFFERING-
IN PERSON- TRANSPORTATION CM
SIXTY SEVEN YARDS ALSO WANTS TO
SELL OUT. OKAY DO YOU KNOW WHY
THAT IS. SO WE'VE HAD DIFFICULTY
GETTING- A CONTRACTOR WILL.
DIFFICULTIES ON WHOSE PART-
MOSTLY ON THE BITTEREST PART-
NOT IT- HAVING THE- THE CORRECT
DOCUMENTS THE CORRECT- HAVING
THE CORRECT OF. ABILITY TO
PROVIDE WHAT WE ARE WHAT WE ARE
REQUESTING- IF IT IS A LOT TO GO
FROM- IN AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- TO ALL TO ALL THIRTY FOUR
INSTITUTION. AND SO WHAT IS YOUR
TIMELINE TO DO TO GET THERE
WE'RE OPEN BY THE END OF THIS
WEEK. BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND THAT'S WHY
THAT'S WHERE YOU EXPECT IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS YES. I'M
SORRY BYE BYE JULY FIFTEENTH THE
END OF TWENTY TWO. AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU EXPECT TO HAVE THE
CONTRACTS SIGNED TO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. CORRECT OKAY- MISTER GUMM
REYES IT'S NOT IT MY INFORMATION
IS THAT ONLY A PORTION OF THE
MONEY ALLOCATED FOR FREE PHONE
CALLING HAS BEEN SPENT- IF
THAT'S TRUE CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY
THAT IS- AND HOW HAVE YOU MADE
OF THE PEOPLE AWARE THAT THE
MINUTES ARE AVAILABLE- AND IS
THERE ADEQUATE ACCESS TO THE
PHONES AVAILABLE. I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE MADELINE CLEANING THAT
MADELINE OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS NATALIE W. TRACTOR FISCAL
SERVICES FOR CCR A SO YOU ARE
CORRECT WE HAVE EXPENDED
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE FREE.
THAT MESSAGING- WE'RE
ANTICIPATING TO SPEND ABOUT TWO
POINT THREE MILLION THIS FISCAL
YEAR ANY ANY FUNDING THAT IS NOT
USE WILL BE REFERRED TO THE
GENERAL FUND- AND IT'S NOT
BECAUSE- OF INTERNET
INCARCERATED PERSONS ARE ALLOWED
TO USE THE PHONES- DURING THEIR
NORMAL TIMES WE'RE NOT
RESTRICTING THE USAGE OF. OTHER
PHONE CALLS. US SO WE ARE. THE
THEY'RE UTILIZING IT WE CAN SEE
THERE YOU'LL THEY GET A HUNDRED
TWENTY- THROUGH THIS. THROUGH
THE BOOK OF THE FUNDING THAT WAS
PROVIDED BY ACT- AND THEY'RE
ALSO USING THE EMAIL MESSAGING
IT'S JUST NOT AS MUCH AS WE HAD
ORIGINALLY BUDGETED FOR WOMEN
WHEN THIS WAS- ADDED TO THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR WAS TOO LATE IN
THE PROCESS AND WE CAME UP WITH
AN- ESTIMATED AMOUNT. BASED ON A
CERTAIN POPULATION LEVELS THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE IN THAT OPERATES
AMOUNT VERSUS WHAT WE GET SPEND
. OKAY AND HAVE USED THE MONEY
TO PROVIDE THE MESSAGING AND
EMAILS THAT LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION. YES SO THE MONEY
WAS VERY IT WAS PERSPECTIVE IN
THE BUDGET ACT AND IT WAS VERY
SPECIFIC ALLOWING FOR THAT FREE
PHONE CALLS AND EMAIL MESSAGES
AND THAT IS WHAT WE ARE USING IT
FOR AND SO THAT COMMUNICATION
HAS BEEN PUT OUT TO ALL
INCARCERATED PERSONS AND THEY
ARE USING- BUT IS THAT WE'VE
SEEN HIM- SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THE USAGE OF A MINUTE AND- I
EMAIL MESSAGES OVER. OVER
PREVIOUS TAX BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE THIS FREE OPTION
OKAY AND THEN- I'M I'M NOT SURE
WHO WOULD ANSWER THIS BUT WITH
THE BIG THERE WAS TESTIMONY
ABOUT. THE APPLICATION PROCESS
TO GET OF A VISIT. THAT THEIR- A
LOT OF. COMPLICATIONS OF THAT
ARE PRESENTED BUT- OF THE
FAMILIES DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW
TO GET PAST THOSE PROBLEMS THEY
DON'T IDENTIFY WHAT THE ISSUE
IS. TO DO THAT DENIES THEM THE
VISITATION- COULD SOMEONE
RESPOND TO THAT. IS THIS IN
REGARDS TO THE- DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN THE RULES YES. OKAY
THEN. SO I WOULD BE ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS. IF THERE IS ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THIS NEED TO
CONTACT AWARD AT SPECIFIC
INSTITUTIONS- TO FIFTEENTH AT
REASONS WHY. YOU MEAN EVERY
INDIVIDUAL PERSON WHO RUNS
ACROSS THAT PROBLEM NEEDS TO
CALL THE WARDEN THEY CAN CONTACT
THE WARDEN OF THE RIGHT THE
LEVEL OF WORK WHICH YOU WILL
HAVE. GET SOME INFORMATION ABOUT
. OKAY I JUST JUST WANNA SAY
OVERALL- I MUST SAY I'M I'M A
BIT DISAPPOINTED IN THE
RESPONSES THAT THIS COMMITTEE-
HAS RECEIVED. OF IT WE KNEW WHAT
THE SUBJECT MATTER WAS FOR THIS
CONVERSATION WE KNEW THE
PARTICULARS- ISSUES. THAT ARE
FACING THE FAMILIES- AND IT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM TO IT DOESN'T SEEM
IT DOESN'T COME IN GET IT
DOESN'T MAKE ME FEEL LIKE THIS
IS SUCH AN URGENCY OF FOR YOU
MEANWHILE THE FAMILIES DEPEND ON
YOU. TO BE ABLE TO VISIT TO BE
ABLE TO SEEK TO BUILD FOR THE
CHILDREN TO SEE THEIR PARENTS
AND IN THIS LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION
OF BEING ABLE TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT- THE DENIALS OF I
MEAN IT JUST SEEMS. LIKE NOT THE
MOST COMPLICATED THING IN THE
WORLD TO RESOLVE BUT YEAH THIS
IS GOING ON AND ON AND ON SO.
MISTER GROW I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
HOW. I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY
ABOUT THIS I FEEL VERY- I FEEL
LIKE THE RESPONSES THAT YOU ALL
SHOULD BE IN A BETTER PLACE. IN
TERMS OF RESPONDING AND HAVING A
REAL PLAN TO FIX IT OTHERWISE IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S GOING ON. MONTH
AFTER MONTH AND EVEN YEAR AFTER
YEAR. A MANAGER- I CONVINCING
AYE CAN I TELL YOU IT IS
IMPORTANT TO US- AND SO WE WILL
DEFINITELY BE LOOKING. INTO WAYS
TO MAKE THINGS BETTER- WE HAVE
CONSTANT DIALOGUE WITH OUR
STATEWIDE- INTERCONNECTIONS
TOMORROW TO SEE WHAT THE ISSUES
ARE AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS BORN TO US WE WILL BE
LOOKING. AND I AND I SAY THAT-
FOR THE GOOD OF EVERYBODY I MEAN
WE WANT THESE. MEN AND WOMEN
WHEN THEY ARE RELEASED TO BE-
YOU KNOW AS STRONG AND
SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE WHEN THEY
ARE RELEASED. AND THIS IS A VERY
VERY CRITICAL PART OF THEM BEING
ABLE TO BE IN THE BEST POSITION.
TO TAKE WE TAKE. CHARGE OF THEIR
LIVES SO I. I DON'T YOU KNOW IF
IT'S A MATTER OF MONEY IF IT'S
SOME WHAT WHAT IS IT PLEASE
IDENTIFY THAT PLEASE LET US KNOW
BECAUSE IT'S UP IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE THE RESOURCES IN THIS
BUDGET COMMITTEE OTHER
RESOURCES. BUT YOU NEED TO LET
US KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON AND HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO FIX IT WHAT'S
THE PLAN TO FIX IT- SO WILL BE
UP WILL BE FOLLOWING UP. WITH
GOOGLE THAT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY
. I AM SURE. YES CAN I JUST A
INDORSE EVERYTHING YOU JUST SAID
AND IT. APPS WE GET ASKED YOU
KNOW GIVEN THE- THE NATURE OF
THE SUB COMMITTEE PROCESS AND-
YOU KNOW TIMING- BETWEEN
MEETINGS DOESN'T ALWAYS LEND
ITSELF TO SOME VERBAL FALL UP IN
TESTIMONY THAT- THAT WE COULD.
ASK FOR A WRITTEN REPORT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ALL
MEMBERS INCLUDING THOSE NOT
PRESENT TODAY- IS AS WELL AS TO
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE OVERALL-
THE WRITTEN REPORT AS TO WHAT
PROGRESS IS MADE IN THE NEXT
THIRTY DAYS SO THAT THE REPORT
WOULD BE BACK TO US IN THE
THIRTIES AND WHAT WHAT I'M
THINKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
TIMING IS- THAT- MAY FIFTEENTH
THIS COMING THE MAY REVISE IS
COMING. I THINK HONOR ABOUT THE
SEVENTEENTH EIGHTEENTH- WE WILL
BE. STARTING TO STUDY THAT. AND
OKAY THEN AND TODAY IS- IN A
TODAY'S THE TWENTY EIGHTH IT
GIVES US YOU KNOW MAYBE TEN DAYS
AFTER THE MAY REVISE- TO LOOK AT
A REPORT. THAT WE WOULD RECEIVE
WITHIN IF THAT'S MY THIRTY DAY
TIME MEET RIGHT THAT WE RECEIVE
ON THE PROGRESS AND I THINK THAT
SHOWS SOME. WE CALLED HOPE I
WILL. GO FURTHER THAN THAT- BUT
THAT- CDCR IN THOSE WHO TOLD US
TODAY THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
FIXES BEFORE THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR- GIVES THEM A CHANCE
TO REPORT BACK TO LET US KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT'S BEEN FIXED WHAT
HASN'T BEFORE WE GET TO THE END
OF HIS CAREER BUT BUT MORE
IMPORTANT BEFORE WE ADOPT THE
NEW AT THE STATE BUDGET IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATION SO I
THINK I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S-
ACCEPTABLE TO YOU AS AS THE
CHAIR- I THINK THAT'S A VERY
GOOD- VERY GOOD SUGGESTION AND I
WOULD ONLY ADD. THAT HOW DO THEY
INTEND TO FIX IT. YES IN IN IN A
IN A REPORT TO US- NO LATER THAN
THIRTY DAYS FROM THE DATE OF
THIS HEARING. OKAY MADAM
CONSULTANT IS THAT OKAY YOU
COULD FOLLOW UP ON THAT. ALL
RIGHT- EVERYONE FROM CDC ARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU FOR THE WORK YOU
EVERY DAY- WE'RE COUNTING ON
YOU- TO FIX THESE. ISSUES AND
GET BACK TO US SO THAT WE CAN
GET THROUGH THIS- BUDGET
PROCESS- FOR THE SAKE OF
EVERYONE- AND I WANT TO THANK
ALSO OF THEM. THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO TESTIFIED TODAY FROM THE
COALITION OF FAMILY UNITY. ARE
YOUR TESTIMONY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT YOU LIVE IT. YOU KNOW
WHAT IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW THE
IMPACT IT'S HAVING WHEN YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO VISITATION WHEN YOU
HAVE- ACCESS WHETHER IT'S- EVEN
IF YOU ADD ON TO THE IN PERSON.
THE VIDEO THE PHONE CALLING THE
TEXTING THOSE IT SEEMS TO ME IS
NOT ONE. OR THE OTHER IT'S ALL
OF THOSE TOGETHER THAT. CREATES
THE BEST A SITUATION FOR OUR
FAMILY SO THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU DO EVERY DAY WITH
OUR- INCARCERATED- MEN AND WOMEN
. OKAY ANYTHING ELSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW-
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TWO IS OUR
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY POINT
ZERO ZERO A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COULD YOU. MAKE THE
PRESENTATION. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON- GERMAN MERCER DO I'VE
OVER THE PART OF FINANCE WILL
GIVE INSPIRATION FOR BOTH YOUR
CONTROL ACTION THAT IT AND
REMIND TECHNICAL WORKLOAD THAT
DEPARTMENT THAT FINANCED AND THE
LEGISLATURE COMPARE EACH YEAR
DURING THE ANNUAL BY DEFAULT
THAT. WEAKENED PROTECTIONS
TWENTY FOCUS ON STREAMLINING-
PRETTY LIMITED COKE OF LANGUAGE
ONLY RECREATION THAT REVERSION
OF FEDERAL BY FOND AND. NON
GOVERNMENTAL CALL. EACH YEAR
MISTREATMENT. TECHNICAL THAT
CONTAIN A LIST OF BOND AND NOT
GOING TO LOOK A GROUP. AND- AND
RIVER AGAIN AND THE IDEA BUDGET
AT. LANGUAGES IS GREAT ONE
EIGHT. BUT DOES REAL VERY DETAIL
ENTERED OF HOW IT. IN ORDER FOR
THE VEHICLE OFFICE TRACK THE
PROCREATION AND REOCCUR. OR
REAPER BE FUNDING AT THE FIVE
AND EVEN IF I'M KEEPING THE A
TYPO OR ERROR IN ELAINE OF AFTER
THE FACT AND THEN APPLY OF THE
GRANT- REFINANCE BETTER. OR
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL IN ORDER
TO MAKE THOSE SMALL TECHNICAL
CHANGE WORK WHICH FURTHER
COMPLICATE THE- BELOW ONLY SOME
OF THE PRICES THAT WE WORK FLOW
OF THAT DEPARTMENT FIND A AND.
AFTER THE DELAY. WARM FALL IN
GETTING A COUPLE LANGUAGE. WITH
THE FOR EACH YEAR DONE- REALLY
BE OUR WHEN ONLY PERFORATION WHY
DON'T- WHILE WE ARE THREE MY
WORK WE ARE STILL A KIND OF LIKE
TO THINK OVER OFF THE THROUGH
THE- JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
WHERE YOU MISTER WITH THE TO
PROVIDE- PRETTY MUCH OF. SIMILAR
THAT WE FROM IN THE- TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUT COMMITTEE
AND THE ABILITY TO- BUT
COMMITTEE OF THE OF THE-
REVERBERATEUNDER. POPULAR STILL
I CAN PLAY A BIGGER I PROPERTY
BUILT IN WITH EXT I DON'T IT
OVER MY CAR- IF.
ADD CREAM AROUND HER SUPPORT AND
FINANCE AND I'M JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THE BULK OF CITIES ARE
PROJECTS ARE TYPICALLY GENERAL
FUND FOR EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL EVERY SINGLE.
PROPOSAL THAT POINT TEN WAS
GENERAL FUND SO MOST OF THE
PROJECTS ARE GENERAL FUND AND
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY WOULD NOT
APPLY TO THEM WE DO HAVE ONE
EXISTING PROJECT RIGHT NOW IT'S
THE C. I. M. S. FIFTY BED AT
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES THAT
ONE IS LEASE REVENUE BOND
FUNDED. SO THAT IS ONE PROJECT
THAT CONTROL TWENTY COULD APPLY
TO YOU- AND THAT COVERS THE
POINTS FROM FOR THE EXTENT OF
HOW CONTROL SECTION TWENTY WHAT
A FLYER COULD APPLY. TO YOU-
CDCR AT THIS POINT IN TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SOMEONE
FROM THE ALEJO'S OFFICE WHO'S
WHO THAT GOING TO BE IS THAT
CAITLYN MISSILE NEIL YES GOOD
AFTERNOON HI HE WENT ON YOU KNOW
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE FIND THAT THE IDEA OF
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS FOR
TECHNICAL AND NON CONTROVERSIAL
BE APPROPRIATIONS AND REVERSION
IT'S REASONABLE- HOWEVER WE DO
KNOW THAT IN GENERAL I CAN BE
MORE CHALLENGING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE.
OVERSIGHT AT- TO PERFORM ITS
OVERSIGHT ROLE THROUGH THE JAIL
THE SHE PROCESS AS COMPARED TO
THE TRADITIONAL BUDGET PROCESS-
AND SO WE RECOMMEND BACK WITH
WHATEVER- REVISED PROCESS IS-
APPROVED SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE-
BE INTERESTED IN ADOPTING THIS
PROPOSAL OR SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
IT- WE RECOMMEND ENSURING THAT
THE PROCESS THAT PROVIDES A
LEGISLATURE WITH THE NECESSARY
TIME AND INFORMATION THAT IT
NEEDS TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT. OF THE AFFECTED
PROJECTS- AND THAT IT IS IT USES
TRULY LIMITED TO THOSE PROJECTS
THAT ARE TECHNICAL AND NON CROP
CONTROVERSIAL IN NATURE- AND SO
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER MODIFYING
THE PROPOSAL IN THREE WAYS OR IN
THREE KIND OF GENERAL CATEGORIES
OF POTENTIAL MODIFICATIONS. AND
THOSE ARE ONE LIMITING THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS TO THOSE THAT ARE
TRULY- TECHNICAL AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL IN NATURE FOR
EXAMPLE. THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER- EXCLUDING PROJECTS AT
PRISONS GIVEN THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND ELSEWHERE ABOUT-
HE DESIRES PLANNING FOR PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN LIGHT
OF. THE DECLINE IN THE INMATE
POPULATION AND POTENTIAL FUTURE
PRISON CLOSURES- IT COULD ALSO-
EXCLUDE. AT LEAST REVENUE BOND
PROJECTS REGARDLESS OF
DEPARTMENT THAT ARE OVER A
CERTAIN DOLLAR THRESHOLDS THAT
WOULD JUSTIFY GIVEN THE SCALE OF
THE PROJECT- INCREASED OVERSIGHT
FOR EXAMPLE- AND THEN THE SECOND
AREA TO CONSIDER WOULD BE
TIMING- SO. IT'S IN SPECIFICALLY
IT IT TENDS TO BE MORE DIFFICULT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO REVIEW
JAIL WE SEE NOTIFICATIONS DURING
PERIODS OF PEAK BUDGET WORKLOAD.
SUCH AS MAY REVISION- AND
CONFERENCE. SO THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER REQUIRING THAT
THESE NOTIFICATIONS ARE
SUBMITTED PRIOR TO MAY FIRST
EVERY YEAR. AND THIRD ON THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER WHAT
INFORMATION IS REQUIRED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH EASE
ON VACATIONS- AND AS WAS STATED
THE- OUT HAS INDICATED THAT IT
INTENDS TO PROVIDE- WITH THE
JAIL BC NOTIFICATIONS- CERTAIN
INFORMATION THAT IS SIMILAR TO
WHAT IT CURRENTLY PROVIDES
THROUGH THE TRADITIONAL BUDGET
PROCESS. HOWEVER IN THE INTEREST
OF FUTURE POLICYMAKERS- THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
MEMORIALIZING THAT INTENT BY
REQUIRING A DEAL AFTER TO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION AS PART
OF THE NOTIFICATION- AND THAT IS
BRING ME TO THE END OF MY
TALKING POINTS BUT I'M AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SENATORS- BE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. OKAY I JUST- JUST TO
CLARIFY THIS IS A CHANGE THAT
WERE ASKING OR- IS BEING PASSED.
A PERMANENT CHANGE RIGHT WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT JUST THIS ONE
ONE TIME FOR THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
. YES WE'RE GONNA BONTA FINANCE
YEAH WE WERE TO TAKE INTENDED TO
BE PERMANENT SO WE WOULDN'T AND
CONTROLLED SECTION TO BE AND
THAT THANKED BUDGET AT YOUR
BUDGET. OKAY I'M WILL THAT SORT
OF HELPS- ANSWER THE- ISSUE FOR
ME WHICH IS I THINK WELL AS
RIGHT NOW THE CARD FOR PROJECT
THAT. WOULD BE COVERED YOU
IDENTIFIED ONLY ONE I THINK THAT
IF YOU'RE ON GOING IF THIS IS
GOING TO BE A PERMANENT CHANGE
IN HOW- OF- IS LANGUAGE IS USED.
THEN I DO THINK THAT- THE L. A.
O.'S. ISSUES OF TIMING AND WHAT
TYPES OF PROJECTS- YOU KNOW I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE FIND A
WHAT A TECHNICAL I GUESS
TECHNICAL IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMMONLY USED- BUT- WHAT'S NON
CONTROVERSIAL. THAT SEEMS TO BE
LANGUAGE JUST A LITTLE BIT
LOOSER SO I DO AGREE WITH THAT
ALLEY- THAT WE NEED TO TIE IN
THIS A BIT SO THAT. WE DON'T
LOSE OUR LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
OF- C. I THINK THAT'S RIGHT I
THINK THAT'S IT FOR ME. OF
NOTHING ELSE THEN WE MOVE ON TO-
ALL RIGHT- THREE ISSUE THREE
WHICH IS COMMUNITY REENTRY
PROGRAMS- I'LL ASK OF. C. FROM
THE ALLELES OFFICE WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING. NEIL AGAIN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE'VE BEEN ASKED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THIS PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEING CONSIDERED BY.
CONCENTRICALLY THE PROPOSAL
WOULD EXPAND COMMUNITY REENTRY
PROGRAMS WHICH PROVIDE ELIGIBLE
INCARCERATED PERSONS WITH A
COMMUNITY BASED RESIDENTIAL
SETTING TO SERVE THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF THEIR SENTENCE. AND
PREPARE THEM FOR RE ENTRY. THESE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE A RANGE OF
COMMUNITY BASED REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES THAT ASSIST WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER MENTAL
HEALTH CARE MEDICAL CARE
EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION AND HOUSING
FAMILY REUNIFICATION AND SOCIAL
SUPPORT. CDCR CURRENTLY OPERATES
TWO OF THESE PROGRAMS- AND THEIR
CULTURE MAIL REUNION MALE
COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAM OR AND
SEE OUR PEACE AND THE CUSTODY TO
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONAL REENTRY
PROGRAM. MORRISSEY CTRP IT WAS
R. FOUR FIVE MEN AND WOMEN
RESPECTIVELY. CURRENTLY THESE
PROGRAMS SERVE THIRTEEN COUNTIES
AND HAVE A CAPACITY OF AROUND A
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS. M. AND
THE INTENT THE ATTENTION AS WE
UNDERSTAND IS TO- ULTIMATELY
ENABLE CDCR TO BUILD OUTS MORE
FACILITIES TO SERVE ADDITIONAL
COUNTIES- AS WELL AS HAVE A
LARGER PORTION OF THE ROUGHLY
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE RELEASED
FROM CDC ARE. GO THROUGH ONE OF
THESE PROGRAMS. YOUR AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER O'NEILL NEXT WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM CDC ARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KEVIN COFFEY AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION-
I WAS GOING TO GIVE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF THE MALE COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAM OF THE CABLE AND
PROVIDED THAT INFORMATION. BUT I
WILL TELL YOU THAT- CURRENTLY
RIGHT NOW FOR THE MALE COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAM WE HAVE SIX
LOCATIONS. WE HAVE ONE LOCATION
TO DO COUNTY THAT'S IN THE CITY
OF OROVILLE ONE LOCATE PATIENT
KERN COUNTY THAT'S IN THE CITY
OF BAKERSFIELD WE HAVE THREE
LOCATIONS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUT ONE OF THEM BEING A LONG
BEACH AND WE HAVE. A LOCATION IN
SAN DIEGO WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
CAPACITY OF SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO AND WE ARE CURRENTLY AT
NINETY FOUR POINT SIX PERCENT.
OF BILLS. OKAY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR HOFFMAN WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM DOUG BOND FROM THE
AMITY. FOUNDATION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS-
OF THE BOND PRESIDENT CEO AMITY
FOUNDATION HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE STRANDED REENTRY
PROGRAMS MANY FOUNDATIONS BEEN
DEDICATED TO THAT INCLUSION
FILTRATION OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN MARGINALIZED BY ADDICTION
TRAUMA CRIMINALITY OR SERRATION
OF POVERTY- AND HAS WORKED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
WITH CDC ARE INSIDE OF
INSTITUTIONS AND HELPING MEN
WHEN THEY COME HOME I CO STRIVE
TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND
PROMOTE ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE FOR THOSE THAT
WE'RE SERVING- WE TALK ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE I'VE REPRESENT THAT
AS WELL IT WAS A SMALL CHILD
DIFFERENT THROUGH OVER A DOZEN
FOSTER HOMES- WELL MY FATHER IS
INCARCERATED BY MOTHERS MCCARTY
STREET IT- SPENT TIME IN
ORPHANAGES THE FOUNDERS. OF OUR
ORGANIZATION ACTUALLY GOT ME OUT
OF FOSTER CARE- MY FATHER WAS
ALTERNATIVELY SENSE DANTE WHERE
I WAS ABLE TO SPEND TWO YEARS
THERE WITH HIM WITH MY SISTER
AND HE WAS ABLE TO GET THE
SERVICES HE NEEDED. TO RETURN
BACK TO PRISON- JUST TIME LATER-
I WAS ALSO IN MY EARLY TWENTIES
SUPPORTERS AND THEN STREET WITH
THE- WENT THROUGH OUR- WHILE.
AND OVER THE LAST TWENTY HAVE
BEEN TO RISE THROUGH THE YOUR-
WORKING VARIOUS- I'VE SEEN THESE
PROGRAMS WITH THE ALTERNATIVE
RELEASE OR THE COMMUNITY RANCHER
PROGRAMS WORK FOR MEN AND WOMEN
THAT ARE COMING HOME STRONG
BELIEVER. AND PATHWAYS BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY AND THE IMPACT IT
HAS ON NOT ONLY THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE BEING SERVED BUT THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS WELL- THE RE
ENTERPRISE JOKES ALLOW PARTISAN
SERVE THE FINAL TWO YEARS AS YOU
HEARD THEY'RE ABLE TO GET HEALTH
CARE. SERVICES EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES TREATMENT SERVICES A
REALLY WIDE RANGE AND VARIETY OF
SERVICES THAT ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL UPON. RELEASE EMSTER
. A LOT OF BACK TO COMMUNITY
BASED WORK. AND THIS IS A
COLLECTIVE AND COLLABORATIVE
PROJECT THAT WORKS WITH THE
DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
BASED PROVIDERS. WHEN YOU REALLY
TALK ABOUT WHAT WORKS THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WHAT WORKS AND IT
REALLY IS THE FUTURE OF WHAT RE
ENTRY SHOULD LOOK LIKE FOR
EVERYONE COMING HOME- IT SHOULD
BE GAINING ACCESS TO.
COMPREHENSIVE REENTRY SERVICES
I'VE SEEN A 180 DEGREES CHANGES
AND I'M IN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
GOING TO PROGRAMS THAT WE
OPERATE BOTH MEN AND WOMEN'S
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
MENTIONED HERE TODAY. RESEARCH
ON THIS IS WELL SUPPORTS IT. WE
SHOULD SHOWN RECENTLY WITH
STANFORD STUDY THAT WE'VE
REDUCED THE ONE YOUR CONVICTION
RATE FROM 12% TO ONE PERCENT.
WHICH IS A 92% REDUCTION. AND
RECIDIVISM RATES AND SO WE'RE
SHOWING VERY SUCCESSFUL US
SUCCESS IN THESE PROGRAMS WE
BELIEVE WITH THESE PROGRAMS
COUPLED WITH HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES IT REALLY IS
A- WAY. TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO MOVE
FROM DEGRADATION DIGNITY AND I
WILL JUST AND ON THE
ENVIRONMENTS THAT WE CREATE FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE RETURNING HOME
IT IS SO IMPORTANT THAT WE IT
WOULD BE FOR NFL TATIAN- PROCESS
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO BE IN A
SAFE. SANCTUARY ENVIRONMENT AND
THE SAN VITAMINS ARE THAT RATHER
THAN. SERVING IN- YOUR SENSE IN
GETTING SERVICES AND A PRESENT
IT'S REALLY ALLOWS PEOPLE TO BE
IN A SAFE PLACE AND SAFELY COME
HOME REUNITE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES. AND JUST REALLY WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
TIME ON THIS AND FOR THE
CONSIDERATION THERE'S NO ONE
SILVER BULLET THAT WILL DO
EVERYTHING FOR EVERYONE COMING
HOME. AND IT REALLY IS A
COLLABORATIVE PROJECT AND
BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE THE
PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE RETURNING
BACK. TO THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU
GREAT. THANK YOU MISTER BOND AND
THE CONGRADULATIONS AND THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR LIFE STORY-
WITH S. R. I WANT TO MOVE ON NOW
TO MISTER. THOMAS KNOWS. KNOWS
THIS. NOW WHICH TRIGGERED NOT AS
OF. THAT WAS AND I KNOW HE MEANT
. I'LL JUST SAY TOM. GREAT NO
SAVE AGAIN IN OTHER WORDS NOT AS
A WITH OKAY THANK YOU WHAT WE'RE
GOOD AT SHARE IN MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH I FOR ME HERE
THIS AFTER THAT TOM KNOWS WHICH
THE LEGAL TO FOR THE COMMITTEE
HONORED OF THE P. CODE RECENTLY
RECOMMENDED EXPANDING THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY SO JUST OF A
BRIEF WORD ON WHAT THE PENAL
CODE COMMITTEE IS IT WAS CREATED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND- IT'S
BEEN IN EXISTENCE SINCE JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY WITH THE MANDATE
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
SIMPLIFY AND RATIONALISE
CRIMINAL LAW IN CALIFORNIA. THE
COMMITTEE'S GOALS ARE TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY WHILE REDUCING
UNNECESSARY INCARCERATION AND
IMPROVING JUSTICE MEDICALLY
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM WE'VE PUT OUT TOO MANY
RECORDS SO FAR IN OUR MOST
RECENT ONE WE RECOMMENDED
EXPANDING THE MCRPC CTRP
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
THIS AFTERNOON- AS YOU HEARD
THESE ARE EXISTING PROGRAMS AT
CDC ARE RUNS THAT ALLOWED PEOPLE
TO SPEND THE LAST MONTHS OF
THEIR INCARCERATION IN. A
SECURED SETTING IN THE
COMMUNITY. THE REASON MANY WAS.
TO THIS I WAS BIG THE RE THAT-
MISTER- SPOKE ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
I WON A- THE- A BIT- THERE IS
RESEARCH FROM THE STANFORD
PUBLIC POLICY PROGRAM THAT- WAS
ABLE TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
CAUSATION WAS ABLE TO. IDENTIFY
A CONTROL GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO.
COULD HAVE GONE INTO AN M. C. R.
P. PROGRAM BUT DIDN'T FOR
REASONS BEYOND THEIR CONTROL AND
THOSE WHO DID COMPLETE THE
PROGRAM SO THEY'RE ACTUALLY ABLE
TO ISOLATE AND SAY. THE M. C. R.
P. HAVE THE HAVE AN EFFECT ON
REDUCING RECIDIVISM THEY
CONCLUDED THAT THAT YES IT DID.
AND YOU KNOW THE STUDY LOOKED AT
MOE THAN EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE WHO WERE RELEASED BETWEEN
SEPTEMBER. TWENTY SIXTEEN IN
JUNE TWENTY NINETEEN SO IT'S
RECENT THAT EXTREMELY RELEVANT
TO THIS ISSUE OBVIOUSLY. WHAT
THE RESEARCHERS FOUND WAS THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMPLETED. NINE
MONTHS AND M. C. R. P. HAD THAT
92% REDUCTION IN THE
RECONNECTION RIGHT THAT MR BOND
MENTIONS THAT SO. THAT'S A BIG
REDUCTION. THEY ALSO FOUND
SIMILAR REDUCTIONS IN THE RE
ARREST RATES SO THE FIRST
PACIFISTIC WITH PEOPLE.
CONVICTED OF NEW OFFENSES AND
THE SECOND ONE IS ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE ARE REARRESTED. AND THEY
FOUND A 20% REDUCTION IN THE
REARREST RATE COMPARED TO THE
CONTROL GROUP FOR FOLKS WHO HAVE
DONE AT LEAST SEVEN MONTHS AND
MCRPC- SO. THESE ARE AS I SAID
THESE RESULTS ARE VERY STRIKING
AND- ARE YOU KNOW IT'S RARE TO
FIND A STUDY OF AN EXACT PROGRAM
THAT YOU WANT TO TRY TO EXPAND
SELECT COMMITTEE- WAS
PARTICULARLY IMPRESSED BY THE
ASSEMBLY. RENDITION OF THIS OVER
A FEW OTHER THINGS THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDERED- THE RECONNECTION
RATE FOR WOMEN WHO GO THROUGH
THE C. C. T. R. P. PROGRAM AND-
YOU KNOW THE ACRONYMS ARE. FAST
AND HEAVY IN THIS WORLD AS WE
KNOW THAT THAT'S THE PROGRAM
THAT. SERVES WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR. THEY HAD A MUCH
LOWER REARREST RATE THAN THE
OVERALL REARREST RATES ALMOST.
20% FOR C. C. T. R. P. VERSUS
35% OVERALL. AND THAT WAS IN THE
CONTROL GROUP STUDY LIKE THE
STANFORD STUDY BUT IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE FINDINGS
AND SUPPORTS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
IMPACTS HERE. AND FINALLY THE
COMMITTEE ALWAYS LIKES TO LOOK
AT WHAT OTHER JURISDICTIONS ARE
DOING- AND TO SEE IF THERE MIGHT
BE THINGS THAT CAN BE TRANSLATED
INTO THE CALIFORNIA CONTACTS.
INDEED THERE IS A HELPFUL MODEL
HERE THAT'S THE FEDERAL BUREAU
OF PRISONS. WHICH NOW HAS MORE
PEOPLE IN ITS PRISONS SOMETHING
WE DO. ALMOST EVERYONE RELEASED
FROM FEDERAL PRISON IS GONNA
SPEND UP TO THE LAST YEAR MAKES
SENSE- SIMILAR PROGRAM- SO AS
YOU AS YOU HEARD YOU KNOW WE'RE
RELEASING THIRTY THOUSAND.
PEOPLE A YEAR FROM PRISON THAT'S
ABOUT EIGHTY PEOPLE A DAY MORE
THAN EIGHTY PEOPLE A DAY. WE
HAVE LESS THAN A THOUSAND OF
THESE BEDS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE-
AND SO BASED ON THAT DATA
RESEARCH THE PENAL CODE
COMMITTEE CONCLUDED. THERE WOULD
BE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS IN
PUBLIC SAFETY AND OTHER POSITIVE
BENEFITS BY EXPANDS PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU AGAIN AT ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
OF. MEMBERS OF. THE COMMENTER
YOU HAVE TO A QUESTION OF MA'AM
SURE THANK YOU ON A I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT- THE FACILITIES
THEMSELVES THAT ARE CONTEMPLATED
THERE- IT WAS REFERENCE TO ABOUT
A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR COST. A
BEFORE TWO HUNDRED BED FACILITY
WHICH SOUNDS LIKE A REALLY GOOD
DEAL- FOR INDIVIDUALIZED SPACE
BUT I'M I'M WONDERING. HELLO I'M
JUST ONE CURIOUS ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE WE LOOK AT. SO MUCH IN
TERMS A SHELTER IN IN OTHER IN
IN OTHER AREAS WITH THE- HOUSE
AND EVERYTHING ELSE- AS TO
WHETHER OR TO WHAT THE BEST
PRACTICES IS HERE IS IT. IS IT-
CONGREGATE SPACE WITH WITH BUNKS
FOR. YOU KNOW X. AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE- THE TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE I
GUESS FOR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
OR FOR THE IN DORM STYLE OUR
INDIVIDUALIZED STYLE OR WHAT'S
CONTEMPLATED THEIR- SO I COULD
SPEAK TO THAT. SO IT IS SHARED
HOUSING- IDEALLY YOU WANT PEOPLE
TO LIVE IN A COMMUNITY TYPE
SETTING- THOSE ARE A DECK TO BE
CLEANED UP THE PREVIOUS PROJECTS
SO MULTI FAMILY HOUSING-
DEPENDING ON THE LAY OUT OF THE
ROOM YOU WILL HAVE- UNDER G. TWO
OR THREE INDIVIDUALS LIVE AND
THEN- SHARED HOUSING AND SO YOU
DO. YOU ARE ABLE TO SERVE MORE
PEOPLE THERE BUT YOU'RE ALSO
REALLY ABLE TO GET THE
THERAPEUTIC AND COMMUNITY
APPROACH WHICH IS REALLY HELPFUL
WALL. OR GOING THROUGH A RE
ENTRY PROCESS. OKAY THEN
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION IN TERMS
OF COSTS THE FIFTEEN MILLION I
WILL ALSO ADD IS- IT DEPENDS ON
THE REGION THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE AND TWO HUNDRED BEDS IS KIND
OF A MAXIMUM NUMBER. MINIMUM
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS FIFTY BEDS
THE SIXTY BED FACILITIES AS WELL
. WE APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH
IT'S EASY FOR ME. TO VISUALIZE-
BUT BUT I'VE ONLY SEEN THOSE
KIND OF FACILITIES- IN ONLY FOR
THE ON HOUSING THE EAST COAST%
WHERE THEY- USE- HOMELESS
SHELTERS LIKE THAT ESPECIALLY
FOR FOLKS WHO. HAVE EXPERIENCE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEMS- THE
END. ME TYPICALLY WILL MATCH
THEM UP TO TWO THREE TO A ROOM
AND THEN TRANSITION TRYING TO
TRANSITION THEM OUT NINETY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS TO.
PERMISSIBLE OF HOUSING
TYPICALLY- I JUST WANT TO SAY IN
OUR OWN COUNTY- WERE NOT WHAT
COUNTIES LISTED FOR THIS PROGRAM
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. OF THE
REENTRY CENTER THERE HAS BEEN A
GREAT SUCCESS OVERALL. BUT ONE
OF THE- SIGNIFICANT ISSUES IS-
LACK OF HOUSING OR THE
EXPIRATION HOUSING VOUCHERS FOR-
A FORT FOR THOSE- CLIENTS IF YOU
WILL OF THE REENTRY CENTER WHO
ARE OTHERWISE STUDENT GREAT- BUT
BUSINESS SUDDENLY CANACCORD
HOUSING IN A VERY HIGH COST OF
LIVING AREA SO ANYWAY I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE. WE ARE EXPANDING-
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW WE'RE HOPING
TO IMPLEMENT OUR ALAMEDA COUNTY
PROGRAM WHICH IS AN OPEN BY JULY
ONE. AND THE HOPE IS TO HAVE THE
SURROUNDING COUNTIES BE PART OF
THE PROGRAM SO I'M NOT SURE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY COULD BE PART
OF THAT BUT WE WILL LOOK INTO
THAT. WELL WASN'T FISHING FOR
THAT BUT I'LL TAKE IT- YOU KNOW
THAT ALSO DEFINITELY DO ANY I
CAN- TO GET THE COUNTY TO BE A
GOOD PARTNER IN THAT IF- IF THAT
ENDS UP BEING THE CASE. THANK
YOU. GREAT ANSWER. SENATOR
NEWMAN THAT NOW I HAVE TO START
MY GREATER THAN ORANGE COUNTY
HAS LIVED IN ORANGE COUNTY SO-
ANY GOOD NEWS ABOUT ORANGE
COUNTY BUT- EDDIE- THIS DOES
SEEM LIKE A VERY PROMISING
PROGRAM- TO MISTER BONDS. POINT
IMMEDIATE- IF IT'S A DEADLY A
COUPLE QUESTIONS. THE WATER I
MIGHT HAVE MISSED IT BUT ON A
PER CAPITA BASIS HOW DOES. YOU
KNOW THE COMMUNITY REENTRY
PROGRAM COST ON A PER CAPITA
BASIS COMPARED TO INCARCERATION
FOR. YOU NOTED THAT THIS POINT
AND I GUESS AS I ASKED THAT- IF
WE'RE LOOKING TO EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM IT SEEMS LIKE WE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT IT WHAT WHAT
ARE. YOU THE SORT OF YOU KNOW
SOME BALLPARK COST AS WE LOOK
FORWARD AS IT COMMITTEE- TO
POSSIBLY ALLOCATING FUNDS TO DO
THAT WHAT WHAT ARE WE LOOKING
FOR TO GET TO SOMETHING
REALISTIC THAT STRESS TO-
REPLICATE EXPAND THIS VERY
PROMISING MODEL. THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I CAN. TRY TO ANSWER
THAT SO THE PER CAPITA COST FOR
US TO PROVIDE SERVICES THAT WE
JUST ALL A COSTS TYPICALLY.
RANGES FROM ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY TO A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
DAY THE PER CAPITA COSTS ON A
FOUR CAR STREET XIN I BELIEVE IS
AROUND TWO HUNDRED NINETY- DAYS
SO. EITHER CERTAINLY COST
SAVINGS THERE BUT YOU ALSO GET
COST SAVINGS ON THE COST
REDUCTION FROM RE CONVICTION
WHICH IS ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
RECONNECTION. THE DENSER THAT'S
OCCURRING SO TO THE EXTENT. IT I
THINK I UNDERSTAND FROM YOUR
YOUR- DESCRIPTION THESE ARE DEAF
TO REASON OTHERWISE YOU'RE
YOU'RE PURCHASING FACILITIES IN
COMMUNITIES SO I ASSUME THAT'S A
SEPARATE COST MISTER BOND- ON ON
TOP OF. THE YOU KNOW THE DAILY
PER CAPITA EXPENSE. SO THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY THE ALL IN COST PAYS
FOR THE COST OF THE FACILITY AS
WELL SO IF WE COULD WORK WITH
LANCE B. OR OTHER- PROPERTY
OWNERS SIDE OF LEASE OR PURCHASE
PROPERTY THAT THE PRICE THAT I
MENTION FOR OUR SERVICES
ACTUALLY INCLUDES THE COST OF
EITHER LEAVES SCENE. OR IT
TYPICALLY LEASING OR PURCHASING
A PROPERTY. BUT SEARCHING CHAU
IS AND THEN IN TERMS OF.
PROSPECTIVE CAPACITY BUILDING
WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU SAY. YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE LIMITATIONS ON
HOW FAST. WE COULD EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM TO GET TO SOMETHING.
LIKE THE NUMBER THAT I THINK I
THINK MR OFTEN DESCRIBE A THIRTY
THOUSAND- IN MY TWO YEAR YOU
KNOW SO HOPEFULLY MOVING THROUGH
THIS PROCESS. I WOULD SAY OUR
ABILITY TO REALLY IDENTIFY- RAMP
UP PURCHASED OR LEASED NEW SITES
AND THEN TRAINED WORK FORCE AND
SO I WOULD BELIEVE THAT. WHAT IS
BEING PROPOSED AS A REALISTIC-
RAMP TO THAT I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
WANT TO ADD TOM ANYTHING TO THAT
IN TERMS OF TIME LINES BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT. WE'RE ABLE TO RAMP
UP. THERE BEFORE ME PROVIDERS
THAT DO THIS SERVICE AND OTHERS
THAT COULD BE BROUGHT INTO THIS
WELL TO DO IT. I'M NOT SURE
KEVIN THEIR ONLINE SEVENTY. YOU
KNOW I THINK THE ONLY THING I
WOULD I WOULD ADD IS- YOU KNOW
IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WE WERE
ABLE TO DOUBLE OUR PRISON
CAPACITY IN ABOUT TEN YEARS SO I
THINK WE'VE SHOWN THAT WE CAN
MAKE THE KIND OF INVESTMENT IN
THE SYRIAN HOPEFULLY IN A- IN A
WAY THAT- IS LITTLE MORE CITIES
A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY THAT WAS
SOMETHING ELSE OF THE PENAL CODE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERED IN MAKING
THIS RECOMMENDATION. GO AHEAD
SIR I WOULD SAY ONE OF THE-
THINGS WE FIND THAT CAN BE
DIFFICULT IT'S CITING. PROGRAMS-
INDIA'S AND OF COURSE- THAT CAN
BE AN ISSUE BUT- SO FAR WE'VE
BEEN PRETTY LUCKY WITH THE
SCIENCE THAT WE HAVE AND I'VE
JUST HEARD IN TERMS OF A NUMBER
LOOKING OUT YOU KNOW ONE TO
THREE YEARS WHAT SHOULD WHAT
SHOULD WE BE. ANTICIPATING BY
WAY OF A OF YOU KNOW THAT ASK
FOR THIS. AND IF AND IF OF IF
WITH THE O'NEILL WANTS TO JUMP
IN AT ANY POINT. PLEASE FEEL
FREE. I WOULD YEAH GO AHEAD
MISCIBLE PLEASE. I WAS JUST
GOING TO OFFER A TWENTY- ARSENIC
VISUAL INFORMATION ON THE PER
CAPITA COST AND YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR NEWMAN- WHILE IT IS TRUE
THAT THE DAILY COST TO HAVE THE
AVERAGE COST TO HOUSE A PERSON
IN A STATE OPERATED PRISON-
COMES OUT TO AROUND. TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS A DAY AT THE
CURRENT AVERAGE COST OF AROUND A
HUNDRED THOUSAND- DOLLARS A YEAR
WHICH IS A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
RIGHT NOW DUE TO THE POPULATION
BEING PARTICULARLY LOW DUE TO
KOBE- I JUST. WANTED TO KNOW
THAT- DEAD COST OF THE STATE
ACTUALLY SAVES ONE IT. NO LONGER
HOUSES A PERSON IN A STATE
OPERATED PRISON. IS CLOSER TO
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS A DAY OR
THIRTEEN THOUSAND A YEAR- THAT'S
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T. THE STATE
DOESN'T GET THE FIXED COST
SAVING ESSENTIALLY DOES.
SALARIES BEING THE BIG TICKET
ITEMS- INTEL IT ACTUALLY CLOSES
A PRISON SO. TO SEE THAT- DOES
FULL SAVINGS ON THE
INCARCERATIONS CIDER THE STATE
OPERATED FACILITY PRISON
FACILITY SIDE. WE WOULD NEED TO-
BE ACTIVATING AND OFF OF THESE
FACILITIES TO BE ABLE TO CLOSE A
PRISON- OR SIGNIFICANT PORTIONS
OF A PRISON TO THIS EXTENT WE
COULD. WRITTEN DOWN THOSE FIXED
COSTS AND- AVERAGE PRISON. IN
THE RANGE OF A FEW THOUSAND
PEOPLE I HOPE THAT HELPS SORRY
FOR INTERRUPTING THAT ACTUALLY
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL SO YOU TO
DRIVE THE POINT WELL TAKEN THANK
YOU. BUT ARE WE STILL ARE STILL
LOOKING FOR A NUMBER EVEN IF
IT'S JUST AND- YOU KNOW VERY
BALLPARK ASPEN. AT DO THAT WE
SHOULD BE THINK ABOUT IT
IRRESPECTIVE OF YOU KNOW THROUGH
THE INTERSECTION OF THOSE. UNITS
OF THE- PER CAPITA YOUR INMATE
VERSUS- REENTRY BUT YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT SHOULD WE I GUESS MR
BOND INVESTORS LIKE YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S A NUMBER THAT WE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT AS FRESH AS WE
LOOK AT. NOT JUST THIS BUDGET
BUT FUTURE BUDGETS- WHAT WHAT DO
YOU WHAT DO YOU THINK BY WHERE
WE DON'T SOMETHING REALISTIC.
YEAH I THINK SOMETHING REALISTIC
OVER THE NEXT- YOU MENTIONED ONE
TO THREE YEARS FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND BETS A YEAR. AS
THOSE NUMBERS INCREASE IN ANSWER
REDUCE SOME OF THE VARIOUS KEVIN
MENTIONED ONE OF THE MAJOR
BARRIERS TO THAT WHICH IS LAND
USE- IN INDIA SOME SO AS THOSE
BARRIERS ARE REDUCED- THE
CAPACITY AND ABILITY TO INCREASE
THOSE. WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE AS WELL. I'M STILL
WAITING FOR A NUMBER. I'VE HEARD
TO BUT YOU THAT'S SO WANT MY-
THIRTY OR DID YOU GIVE IT TO ME
I MISSED IT. I WOULD HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT SENATOR I
PROJECT. THE BIG DEAD BUT I
THINK WOULD BE HEALTH. IT'S
GREAT AND I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS MAY BE TO MISTER
HOFFMAN HOW- HOW DO YOU DECIDE
WHO GETS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE-
IN THE CURRENT PROGRAMS- GIVEN
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
LIMITED. CAPACITY OF- IS THERE
AND WAIT LIST YOU KNOW. HOW DO
PEOPLE BECOME. ELIGIBLE FOR IT.
I'M SURE THE PROGRAM IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
GO TO THE PROGRAM FILL OUT AN
APPLICATION. IT IS REVIEWED- OF
THEIR CRIMINAL HISTORY AND THERE
THERE ARE CHARGES ARE REVIEWED
ON VARIOUS CRITERIA- THERE ARE
SOME INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM- BUT
IT'S A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. AND
PRIOR TO CODE WE WERE- YOU KNOW
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS FOR WORK
WERE VERY HIGH AND NUMBERS IN
THE NINETIES CONSTANTLY- AND
WE'RE GETTING BACK TO THAT RIGHT
NOW- SO WE HAVE A CONSTANT LIST
OF INDIVIDUALS AND THE
INSTITUTIONS. THAT ARE
INTERESTED IT'S NOT OVERWHELMING
SO WE DON'T NECESSARILY- MAYBE
WE HAVE SOME WAITING LIST IN LA
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE ABOUT FIELD.
JEWEL'S YOU KNOW THEY CONTINUE
TO ROLL OUT THE PROBE BASED ON
THEIR REAL STATES. THERE WILL BE
NO I HAVE. BEEN STEP BACK. BUT
IT IS A VOTE. PROGRAM AND THERE
IS A CRITERIA THAT- ALLOWS THEM
TO COME TO THE PROGRAM. AND IS
THERE A WAIT LIST. WE'RE NOT
NECESSARILY A WAIT LIST WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS I WE
HAVE A WHAT WE CALL SHAREPOINT.
AND THE END OF THE POTENTIAL
ELIGIBLE- PARTICIPANTS ARE IN A
SHAREPOINT AND WE'RE GOING TO
THOSE ALL THE TIME BUT AT THIS
TIME WERE WERE ACCOMMODATING
INDIVIDUALS GETTING OUT THERE-
ARE THERE COULD BE ONE IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW THAT.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE CODE
RESTRICTIONS ANYMORE- SO AS OF
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY A WAIT LIST BUT
THERE ARE. A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE LOS ANGELES
AREA THEY MIGHT NOT BE THE TIME
FRAME THAT EITHER THEY'RE IN THE
SHAREPOINT BUT THERE'S- YOU KNOW
WE CAN GET HIM OUT THERE UP TO
TWO YEARS PRIOR TO THE RELEASE.
AND SO WE HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
THEY CAN. YOU KNOW THEY'RE OUT
THAT TO YOUR POINT SO WE CAN GET
HIM OUT THERE- SO THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY A WEIGHTLESS RENDON
. WELL AS AS I THINK YOU'RE
HEARING OF MR HOFFMAN AND OTHERS
WE- I THINK THERE'S A REAL.
POSITIVE YOU KNOW SUPPORT. OF
FOR THIS THIS PROGRAM AND TO THE
DEGREE THAT. YOU KNOW THE
FUNDING WE CAN HELP THEM GET THE
FUNDING THERE TO THE DEGREE THAT
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO
THIS CAN BUILD THEIR CAPACITY
YOU HAVE THE CAPACITY TO MOVE
MORE- I THINK REALLY- WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION SO-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO THAT AND NOT
CREATE NOT HAVE A WAIT LIST. BUT
HAVE A CONTINUOUSLY GROWING- SO
THAT WE COULD GET MORE
INDIVIDUALS THROUGH A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS. THOUGH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF I THINK THAT'S IT FOR
THIS HERE. THANKS THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO WHO TESTIFIED
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HARD WORK.
OKAY WE'RE MOVING ON TO ISSUE
FOR WHICH IS REAL TIME
MEASUREMENT OF PAROLED
PROGRAMMING AND OUTCOMES. SO
WITH FAST. THREE IF YOU FOR OKAY
FIRST WE'RE GOING TO HAVE OF THE
L. A. O.'S OFFICE. RESENT WHO IS
THAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SANDERS NEEDS ORLANDO SANCHEZ
WITH THE L. A. L. HI COMMITTEE
STAFFERS ASKED WAS TO PRESENT
THIS ITEM THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING A PROPOSAL TO ENABLE
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS OF CDCR
STAYED ON REENTRY PROGRAMMING
AND OUTCOMES. ALSO WOULD ENABLE
CDCR OVER WITH RECIDIVIST IN
NONPROFIT THAT SPECIALIZES IN
ANALYZING CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA.
TO DEVELOP A DATA COLLECTION AND
VISUALIZATION TOOL TO ANALYZE
REENTRY OUTCOMES IN THE CONTEXT.
OF COMMUNITY CHARACTERISTICS
SUCH AS HEAVY AVAILABILITY OF
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
EMPLOYMENT AND TREATMENT. AND
CUSTOMER TO THE PANELISTS CAN
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU ORLANDO THAT
WAS THAT WAS REALLY HELPFUL AND-
GOOD AFTERNOON- CENTERS DRAWS-
CORTESE AND NEWMAN- THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME HERE. MY NAME IS
SUMMER DEAR AND I'M HONORED TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT HOW WE CAN
USE TECHNOLOGY TO IMPROVE PEARL
OUT COMES IN CALIFORNIA. OVER
THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS OUR STATE
HAS SUCCESSFULLY REDUCED. IS
INCARCERATED POPULATION FROM A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
THE CLOSER TO ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. AND THIS IS A SIGNAL
OF AN ONGOING COMMITMENT TO
DIVERTING RESOURCES AWAY FROM
CAPACITY ATION. AND REINVESTING
THEM IN REINFORCING STRONG
DRIVING COMMUNITIES. NO PAROLE
IS A CORE PART OF THAT STRATEGY.
TODAY CALIFORNIA INVESTS OVER
NINE HER MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN RURAL SERVICES. AS
YOU HEARD FROM ORLANDO THAT
INCLUDES THINGS LIKE HOUSING
SERVICES EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENTS- AND SO
ON- ALL THESE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
RE ENTERING OUR COMMUNITIES- AND
DESPITE THIS WE DON'T HAVE
RELIABLE REAL TIME DATA AND
MEASUREMENTS. TO TELL US HOW
EFFECTIVE ARE VESTED INVESTMENTS
ARE- AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THIS PROPOSAL ENABLE. SO AS YOU
HEARD I WORK AT RECIDIVISTS- A
NONPROFIT THAT BUILDS TECHNOLOGY
TOOLS WITHIN CORRECTIONS. WE
CURRENTLY WORK IN NINE STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND WE CAN
ENABLE DATA DRIVEN DECISION
MAKING WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S FOR
ALL PROCESSES- OUR TOOLS WILL
ASSESS REENTRY SERVICES
INVESTMENTS. ENABLING CALIFORNIA
TO DO MORE OF WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT'S OF WHAT'S NOT. SO WE CAN
HELP YOU GET ANSWERS TO KEY
QUESTIONS LIKE IS A PARTICULAR
PROGRAM INCREASING STABLE
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE RETURNING
FROM PRISON- WHAT SHARE OF
INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE WHO
COMPLETES A MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT PROGRAM SECURES THE
JOB. AND HOW DO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF PROGRAMS
COMPARE ACROSS DIFFERENT
DEMOGRAPHICS THINGS LIKE RACE
SEX AND AGE- AND OF COURSE
GEOGRAPHIC FACTORS. THE REAL
TIME MEASUREMENT ABRIL
PROGRAMMING OUTCOMES CAN
UNIQUELY IN POWER OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO OVERSEE AND
IMPROVE REENTRY ACROSS THE
STATE- AND THAT'S WHERE ROSEN TO
DO HERE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
. THANK YOU- MISTER DEAR- GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO A QUESTIONS
FROM OUR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO
NO- I JUST HAVE A- IF YOU COULD
MISTER DEAR- PROVIDE SOME
EXAMPLES OF ANALYSIS YOU HAVE
DONE FOR OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY LED TO A POLICY CHANGE
. OH ABSOLUTELY SO- THERE'S
THREE TYPES OF SERVICES THAT AND
TOOLS THAT WE BILLS- SO BRIEFLY
THOSE ARE MINE STAFF TOOLS
LEADERSHIP TOOLS AND PUBLIC
TOOLS- SO THE PUBLIC TOOLS I
WELCOME YOU TO COME TAKE A LOOK
AT. OUR WEBSITE YOU CAN SEE
DASHBOARDS FOR PENNSYLVANIA AND
NORTH DAKOTA WHERE WE'VE SHOWN-
BOTH PAROLE SUPERVISION
POPULATIONS OF PROBATION AS WELL
AS FACILITY POPULATIONS- AND
THAT LED TO- THAT THOSE INSIGHTS
THIS REAL TIME MEASUREMENTS LEAD
PENNSYLVANIA TO CHANGE ITS
POLICY ON GERIATRIC PAROLE. I'M
RECOGNIZING THAT IN A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE- IN THE FACILITIES WERE
OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY IN THAT
CASE- AND THAT WAS DRIVEN
DIRECTLY BY NOT ONLY THE DATA
BUT ALSO HAVING IT- TRANSPARENT
AND AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC-
SAYS OF THE PUBLIC. DASHBOARD
SIDE- WE ALSO BUILD- LINE
SETTLES TOOLS FOR. EARLY IN TO
BETTER UNDER WHAT'S- WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT BASED. AND WE WILL
USE THAT IN MANY STATES
INCLUDING IDAHO NORTH DAKOTA
ETCETERA THERE'S A GREAT VIDEO
ACTUALLY IF YOU'RE INTERESTED-
ON YOU TOO BUT JUST ONE OF A FEW
WEEKS AGO ABOUT HOW IN IDAHO WE
WERE ABLE TO- ROUTE- EITHER-
RELEASED FROM SUPERVISION
ALTOGETHER OR REDUCE THE
SUPERVISION LEVEL. OF 5% OF THE
PEOPLE ON PAROLE JUST BE JUST
JUST BY- MANAGING THE DATA AS IN
THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE ALREADY BUT
IDAHO'S DATA SYSTEMS- WEREN'T
EQUIPPED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT AND
SO WE AS RESIDENTS WERE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN- AND THEN
THURSDAY IS LEADERSHIP TOOLS AND
THAT'S YOU CENTER ON ONGOING
BASIS FOR- IN MOST CASES THEY DO
YOU SEE LEADERSHIP TO SEE. IN
REAL TIME HOW THE REFORMS AND IN
MANY CASES CHANGES THEY'RE
MAKING- AFFECTS THEIR
POPULATIONS- NOT ON A- ANNUAL OR
QUARTERLY. BUT ACTUALLY ON A
WEEKLY BASIS IN REAL TIME. OKAY
AND COULD HOW LONG YOU BEEN TO
THIS WHAT WHAT IS THE- WHEN DID
YOU COME UP WITH THIS IDEA- SO
WE'VE BEEN AROUND AS AN
ORGANIZATION FOR A LITTLE BIT
OVER THREE YEARS. WE STARTED AS
A WHAT'S CALLED A 20% PROJECT IN
GOOGLE- SO OUR FOUNDERS ARE.
FORMER GOOGLE- AND TECHNOLOGISTS
AND- AND THEN EMERGE OUT OF
GOOGLE I OR THE ORIGINS BECOME
KIND OF BEFORE THOSE THREE OUT
HERE THIRTY THREE SHARES- BUT
WE'VE BEEN A NONPROFIT FOR ABOUT
THAT MUCH TIME. YOU KNOW- WHEN I
WAS READING ABOUT THIS IT. KIND
OF REMINDED ME I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS CORRECT- TO MAKE THIS
CONNECTION BUT WHAT WAS THAT OF
BASEBALL MONEYBALL. IT IS THIS
IS THIS KIND OF LIKE ALONG THOSE
LINES OR OR MY TOTALLY OFF. AS
IT'S A GOOD PARALLEL ACTUALLY SO
IT IN BUSINESS ELEMENTS OF
SOFTWARE ENGINEERING THAT GOES
IN INTO THIS AND THEN THERE'S AN
ELEMENT OF DATA SCIENCE. AND
CERTAINLY ON THE DESIGN SIDE IT
CAN FEEL LIKE MONEYBALL IN THAT-
WE CAN JUST BETTER UNDERSTANDS.
WHAT THE DATA MEANS WHAT THE
NUMBERS MEAN- IN REAL TIME BUT
ALSO PROJECTING INTO THE FUTURE
AND SOME MONEYWHILE YOU'RE
SAYING. ESSENTIALLY DATA
PROJECTION WHICH WE ALSO DO. NOT
OKAY. OKAY I. CAN I CAN INCREASE
OF COURSE THANK YOU I- FIRST OF
ALL THE JUDGES ONE OF THE CHAIRS
MY LEAF ENDED. THE GERIATRIC
APPLIES TO PEOPLE OVER. AND ALSO
AGAIN YOU I'M NOT SIX RIGHT I'M
COOL WITH IT- BUT I AM CURIOUS
ABOUT THE UNIT YOU KNOW TO YOUR
ENGAGEMENT MODEL RIGHT SO DID IN
MY EXPERIENCE WHICH WAS STATE
GOVERNMENT. WE'RE NOT AS GOOD
WITH DATA AS- I THINK WE'D LIKE
TO BE WHEN I WAS GOOD WITH
TECHNOLOGY ON BOARDING AS WE
LIKE TO BE. SO YOU KNOW IT WENT
RECIDIVISTS IS ENGAGE WHAT
WHAT'S THE RELATIONSHIP. HOW TO
HOW DOES IT WORK SO THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S SOME INFO SURE
INSTEAD- PEOPLE WILL BE LOOKING
AT AND TRIPPING THE DATA WELL.
THAT'S THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION-
TO. YEAH THERE THERE THERE'S TO
ENGAGE IN MODELS- BUT I THINK
ARE IMPORTANT HERE. WHAT IS OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE D. O. C.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IN
THIS CASE CDCR- IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- THE FOUNDER LINE DATA
THAT FLOOD AS IF THAT. IS
NECESSARY FOR US TO DO REALLY
MEANINGFUL WORK- IS DATA THE CDC
ARE- HAS A HISTORICAL DATA- SO
BUT- I'M GLAD TO SAY WE HAVE A
DATA SHARING AGREEMENT WITH CDCR
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM ON A
NUMBER OF OTHER FRONTS- THAT.
THAT LINE STAFF TOOLS- TOOL THAT
I MENTIONED FOR PAROLE OFFICERS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
TALKING CDCR ABOUT- ROLLING OUT.
SELLING BEST IN TERMS OF GETTING
THE BEST THAT'S THE FIRST THE
STRIDES IT'S MAKING SURE WE HAVE
THE RIGHT DATA. THAT WE'RE-
SPEAKING WITH AND CONNECTING
WITH THEIR- RESEARCH AND
TECHNOLOGY TEAMS. ALL OF WHICH
IN CALIFORNIA ARE ARE LINING UP-
AND THEN YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT
THAT ON THE- LEGISLATURE SIDE.
IT'S IMPORTANT NOT JUST TO HAVE
THE DATE OUT THERE BUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S EASILY
UNDERSTANDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE-
AND I AND AGAIN I WOULD
ENCOURAGE- I THINK. MY FAVORITE
THING TO SHOW FOLKS AND IF YOU
IF YOU WANT EVEN SCREEN SHARE-
BUT BUT EVERYTHING IS TO YOU THE
DASHBOARDS FOR. AGAIN
PENNSYLVANIA NORTH DAKOTA JUST.
GOOGLE RECIDIVISM. D. I. D. I.
Z. AT THE END- AND PENNSYLVANIA
YOU'LL SEE IT'S- AND YOU'LL SEE
HOW EASY IT IS TO UNDERSTAND THE
DATA HOW YOU CAN CHANGE- THE
DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHICS THAT YOU
WANT TO SEE. IN BEEN VERY SIMPLE
TO UNDERSTAND VISUALS- AND IN
ADDITION IF YOU GO TO OUR
WEBSITE YOU'LL SEE IF YOU CLICK
ON THE- ON POLICY. YOU'LL SEE
THAT WE NOT ONLY JUST SHOW THE
DATA IN VISUALISATIONS. WE ALSO-
ENCAPSULATE THEM IN ONE PAGE
POLICY MEMOS. SO YOU'LL SEE ON
THAT LIST- ACTUALLY DID BEGIN TO
THE DATA SCIENCE MONEYBALL
QUESTION- YOU'LL SEE THAT WE
HAVE ONE PAGE MEMOS FOR THE
REQUESTED BY. DIFFERENT STATES
AND SOMETHING SOME CASES THEY
SENATORS ACTUALLY- WHO WANT TO
UNDERSTAND FOR EXAMPLE WHAT A
POLICY. WILL MEAN IN TERMS OF-
THE IMPACT ON POP. AND ON THE
STATE'S ABOUT- AND WE- PUT THE-
IN ONE- EASY. VISUALS A THAT-
MAKE IT EASIER TO GROW. AT
ACTUALLY PRETTY COOL- AND SO
WHAT WHAT. YOU KNOW KIND OF
WHAT'S THE BASE THERE IS A WORD
WITH. STATE RETAINS YOU- OF ALL
ALL INCOME YOUR WORD IT ON A-
KIND OF EBAY SINCE OF YOU KNOW
WERE WILL. WORK DONE IN KERR'S
THIS BECAUSE HER HAS WORK
FISHING FOR LIKE LOW AT THE- AGE
SAID A OF POCKET. YES IT'S A SET
ANNUAL. AND THEN AND THAT'S
WHAT'S INCLUDED IN ABOUT- AND
FOR THAT YOU GET. ALL OF OUR
PRODUCTS- SO THE IT'S A BIT
LIKE. MICROSOFT OFFICE IF YOU IF
YOU WILL- WHERE- YOU PAY A SET
LICENSE FEE AND YOU GET
EVERYTHING THAT WE BUILD SO FOR
EXAMPLE. IF WE BUILD A DIFFERENT
TOOL FOR OREGON OR- OR TENNESSEE
FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE WE LEARNED
THAT THEY HAVE A CERTAIN NEED-
CALIFORNIA THEN GETS ACCESS THAT
TOO AS WELL- AND THAT'S BECAUSE
WE'RE WE- UNDERSTAND THAT. THERE
ARE WHILE EVERY STATE IS
DIFFERENT THERE ARE PARALLEL
NEEDS ACROSS THEM- AND WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT THOSE-
GET SHARED- SO THIS IS A SET
FEE. FOR THEM OUR TOOLS ARE OUR
PRODUCTS- THE SECOND PIECE THAT
I MENTIONED ABOUT. THE POLICY
MEMOS THOSE ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDE
FOR FREE- SO ANYONE CAN GO ON
THERE YOU CAN GO ON THERE TODAY
AND REQUEST THE MEMO IF YOU'VE
GOT SOME POLICY THAT YOU'DLIKE
TO SEE MOLD OUT. WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO PROVIDE
THOSE- AT NO COST- PARTLY
BECAUSE- IN A- TO. LET'S ASKING
FOR THE BILL'S MEMOS WE ALSO
GET- THIRD PARTIES LIKE THE ACLU
AND ACTUALLY I SHOULD MENTION.
ORGANIZATIONS ON ALL- ENDS OF
THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM- ASKING
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
STYLE- POLICY MEMOS THEY CAN GO
ON THERE AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GET THAT FOR FREE.
CHOI THAT'S REALLY INTERESTING
SO- I GUESS HOW IT WORKS AS A
DATA SCIENTIST WOULD GO LOOK
GOOD. YOU KNOW THE DATA WITH AN
EYE TOWARD COMING WITH A POLICY
RECOMMENDATION SO IT IS.
RECIDIVISTS IT'S IF YOU'RE A FOR
PROFIT ENTITY RADIORAGE OR YOU
DON'T KNOW YOUR NONPROFIT.
NONPROFIT WERE PHARMACY THREE OH
CANCER OKAY YEAH OKAY NO SOURCES
MORE SO. YEAH NOT NOT. OUR
IMPORTANTLY NOT. STE TO DO. OF A
SMALL. AMENDMENTS SAY WE IT
WOULD BE THAT WE'RE GOING TO. A
POLICY. IT'S A POLICY THAT
YOU'RE WILL TELL YOU WHAT WILL
HAVE WHAT IT'LL WHAT IF IT'LL
HAVE WE'LL TELL YOU WHAT THAT
MEANS IN TURN OF- POPULATION
PROJECTION TERMS OF COST THE
STATE ETCETERA- WE DO NOT GET AN
OPINION ON IT WE JUST TELL YOU
WHAT- OUR DATA SAYS. WILL
HAPPEN- AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE AGAIN THAT'S OFFERED FOR
FREE- AND IT'S WE WERE ABLE TO
FIND THAT IS ACTUALLY THROUGH
PHILANTHROPY SO WE RAISE MONEY
TO SAY HERE'S THIS NONPARTISAN.
DATA SCIENCE TOOL THAT WE
UNDERSTAND ORGANIZATIONS CANNOT
AFFORD- OR NOT THIS CASE
LEGISLATORS. HAVE THE RESOURCES
FOR- AND WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT I GET ASSESSED WITH REAL
DATA DRIVEN MEASUREMENT. ISSUE
THAT THANK YOU MEASURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
. MISTER YOU MISTER DEAR- YOU
VERY- FOR YOUR INFORMATION WE'RE
GOING TO ON TO ISSUE FIVE WHICH
IS WITH THE BOARD OF STATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS IT'S THE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE FUND
STABILIZATION WE'RE GONNA HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MAKE A
PRESENTATION PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I JUST NEED A MEMBER
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
I'LL PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
TO TEMPORARILY PAUSE THE SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT FORMULA OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ESTABLISHED THAT
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES FONG-
ACTIVE TWO THOUSAND NINE OR THAT
SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT PROGRAM-
WITH TWO MAJOR PURPOSES ONE WAS
TO LEVY STATE PRISON
OVERCROWDING IN TWO WAYS TO SAVE
GENERAL FUND MONIES. ARE THESE
GOALS ARE ACCOMPLISHED WITHOUT
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY BY
ENCOURAGING COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT'S USE EVIDENCE BASED
SUPERVISION PRACTICES TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS ON
FELONY SUPERVISION SENT TO STATE
PRISONS. SB SIX SEVENTY GRANTS
ARE INTENDED TO INCENTIVIZE
THESE PRACTICES IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SB SIX ANY ALLOCATED ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE COUNTIES
THE REQUIRED TO ANNUALLY REPORT
TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON HOW
TO USE THESE FUNDS. MY APOLOGIES
FOR GETTING A LITTLE TECHNICAL
HERE BUT SIX SEVEN EIGHT FUNDS
ARE BASED ON THREE COMPONENTS
ARE THE FIRST IS A COMPARISON OF
THE RETURN TO PRISON RATE
DETERMINED BY HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ON FELONY
SUPERVISION ARE. PRISON OUT OF
THE COUNTY FOR ALL MANY
SUPERFICIAL POPULATION THE
SECOND IS A COMPONENT OF EACH
COUNTY'S MOST RECENT RETURN TO
PRISON RATE AND A COMPARISON
AGAINST THE COUNTY'S RATE IN THE
PRIOR YEAR HI THIS IS A
COMPARISON OF YEAR TO YEAR DATA
AND PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVE PAYMENT COUNTIES. IT'S
AN FEWER INDIVIDUALS TO PRISON
FROM SAUDI SUPERVISION THAN THEY
DID IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR THE
THIRD COMPONENT IS TO ESTABLISH
A FLOOR IT PROVIDES A MINIMUM OF
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ALL
COUNTIES THAT REPORTED DATA AS
REQUIRED BY THE STATUTE. A CODE
NINETEEN HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
AFFECTED THE FIRST TWO
COMPONENTS I TO GIVE A DETAILED
COMPARISON AND PERSPECTIVE OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE STATEWIDE-
REVOCATION RATE WAS ABOUT THREE
POINT 6% AND THERE ARE AROUND
EIGHT THOUSAND FELONY PROBATION
REVOCATIONS WHO WERE SENT BACK
TO PRISON. WHICH WERE.
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED TWELVE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
HOWEVER DURING THE TWO TWENTY
YEAR. AND IN THE MIDST OF THAT
BUT- ONLY FRACTION THE KIND OF
STANDARD NUMBER OF IN. ON PRO
WERE RETURNED PRISON OUT BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC POLICIES IMPACTS
THE COURTS AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND HAD THE
STATUTORY FORMULA REMAIN THE
SAME THIS WOULD HAVE RESULTED IN
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS PROVIDED TO
COUNTIES FOR THESE PURPOSES-
WHICH IS WHY LAST YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISH A TEMPORARY PAUSE-
AND- AT A FUNDING SCHEDULED TO
PROVIDE. A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR THE
GRANTS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- THE AMOUNT WAS
DETERMINED FROM THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF PAYMENT BY EACH COUNTY
HAD RECEIVED OVER THE PRIOR
THREE YEARS- AGAIN. THAT WAS
JUST A ONE YEAR POLICY THOUGH
AND WE CONTINUE TO SEE THAT
PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON THE
EXISTING FORMULA. OUR DATA SO
FAR FROM COUNTY OR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HAS SHOWN AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER RIGHT REVOCATIONS
COMPARED TO TWENTY TWENTY. AB
COVER NINETEEN VERY OUTBREAKS
SUCH AS DELTON ON THE CRIME. YOU
TO COMPLICATE THE SITUATION AND
DIFFERENT COUNTY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR PRACTICES VERY CONSIDERABLY.
OUT WE ACTUALLY ANTICIPATE THESE
CHANGES BECAUSE OF COVERAGE-
WILL CONTINUE TO REFLECT IN THE
NORMAL DATA. FOR SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT THROUGH CALENDAR YEARS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE. I
WHICH IS WHY THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO PROPOSE THAT ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR PODS. IN THE
FUNDING THROUGH A FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
WE ANTICIPATE KIND OF THAT THE
LONG TAIL A LINGERING IMPACTS OF
THE PANDEMIC WILL. FULLY
DISSIPATE FROM THE DATA- FINALLY
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT. THIS PROPOSAL IS TEMPORARY
. XIN IS COMMITTED T REVISING
FORMULA NEXT. AFTER THE FACT
DEPEND FOR NO. OF IN THE DATA I
ENSURE THAT THE- MAINTAINS THIS
OF THINGS. COUNTY FOR
DEPARTMENT'S IN MAY. CALIFORNIA
PRISON POPULATION I WITHOUT A
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
MISTER ADELMAN- WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THE L. A. O. NOW AND- WHO
WILL BE DOING THAT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND IT'LL BE PER
LINE A SENTENCE AGAIN OKAY. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
EXTENDED THE PROPOSED
MODIFICATION OF FORMULA ON A ONE
YEAR CASES AS OPPOSED TO THREE.
THE EXTENT ANY ADJUSTMENTS ARE
NECESSARY IN THE FUTURE THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD PROPOSE-
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION AS
PART OF THE TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR BUDGET PROCESS. TWO MAIN
REASONS THAT ARE LEADING TO OUR
RECOMMENDATION. THAT FIRST IT IS
UNCLEAR WHY MODIFYING THE
FORMULA FOR THREE YEARS IS
NECESSARY. GIVEN THAT THE FULL
SET OF INFORMATION IS NOT YET
AVAILABLE. RIGHT AND THEN SECOND
THE PROPOSED MODIFICATION COULD
UNNECESSARILY UNDERMINE THE
INTENT OF SB SIX SEVENTY TWO
AWARD COUNTIES BASED ON
PERFORMANCE. WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
FURTHER ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
GROUND MAY BE NECESSARY IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. BUT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER SUCH SUGGESTIONS
AT THAT TIME WHEN IT. AND IT'LL
HAVE MORE INFORMATION TO DO SO
YOU CAN I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. AS NEEDED. GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- SENATOR
NEWMAN. I GUESS JUST A REAL
QUICK QUESTION FOR ELLIE OF. I'M
SO WE'RE WE'RE MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS TO OBJECT TO THE
FORM OF ID DO WE HAVE DATA ARE
THE COMPELLING SHOWS THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS DOES IT WORK IS IT A
CHEATING ITS DESIRED EFFECT OVER
TIME. THIS IS TRUE SO TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SO ON IT PRIOR TO THE
FORMULA BEING PAS- THEY DIDN'T
COLLECT DATA ON THE NUMBER OF.
PEOPLE WHO WERE ON COUNTY FELONY
SUPERVISION WHO WERE PREVENTED
FROM COMING TO THE STATE- AN
ESTIMATE OF THAT AMOUNT AND IT
DID SUGGEST THAT THERE WERE
PEOPLE WHO OF YOUR TO BE
PREVENTED FROM COMING TO STATE
PRISON AS A RESULT OF THE
PROGRAM. AND HAS THERE EVER BEEN
ANY PROCESS ON A UNITS FOR THE
NOTE AND R. O. Y. SORT OF METRIC
TO SEE IF THIS IS BE MORE.
IMPACTFUL ARE BETTER USE OF
FUNDS AND OTHER APPROACHES. SO
THE WAY THE PROGRAM WORKS THE
WAY THEIR PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY
DESIGNED WAS THAT IT WAS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE A PORTION OF
THE STATE SAVINGS THAT OCCURS.
WHEN ALL INDIVIDUALS ARE
PREVENTED FROM COMING FROM. A
STATE PRISON SO WHEN THIS WILL
THE PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY
DEVELOPED THAT AMOUNT WAS TAGGED
AT ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS- COOL PER- FELONY
PROBATION OR DIVERTED FROM STATE
PRISON. SINCE THEN AND SO AT
THAT POINT- IT WAS- RELATIVELY
CLEAR THAT THE STATE WAS
ACHIEVING SOME SAVINGS. SINCE
THE PROGRAM HAS EVOLVED OVER
TIME TO HAVE DIFFERENT POTS. AND
ALSO BECAUSE STATE PRISON COSTS
HAVE CHANGED FROM WHEN THE
PROGRAM WAS FIRST DONE. ON THAT.
DAY IT'S A LITTLE BIT LESS CLEAR
AS TO HOW THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM COMPARES TO THE SAVINGS. BUT THAT'S SOMETHING CERTAINLY
WORTH EXPLORING. IF THAT DID NOT
DIED THANK YOU- YES N. M. FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MISTER
ADELMAN COULD YOU. RESPOND TO
THESE ISSUES I KNOW AND IT'S
SOMEWHAT MADE REFERENCE IS HERE
WE ARE GUARANTEEING OUR FUNDING
WHEN IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE BASED SO
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT.
AGAIN I THINK THE ISSUE AND
WHILE WE'RE GONE WE'RE PROPOSING
KIND OF THIS TEMPORARY FREEZE IS
BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE IN THE MIDST OF THE
PANDEMIC WHICH COUNTIES ARE
ACTUALLY PERFORMING KIND OF DIS
INCENTIVE BASED PROGRAMS AND
INITIATIVES. TO HAVE FEWER-
INDIVIDUALS RETURNED TO PRISON
OR IF THERE ARE OTHER KINDS
EXTERNAL FACTORS THAT ARE
REDUCING THEIR RETURN TO PRISON
RIGHT NOW IT'S COUNTIES- YOU
KNOW SOME COUNTIES HAD A MAKRAN
SHUTDOWNS IN OUR COURT SYSTEM
THROUGH- JANUARY- THERE IS A
LIMITED INTAKE TO STATE PRISONS
THROUGH FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ENDS AND SO WE'RE
SEEING KIND OF THIS THIS NOISE
IN THE DATA THESE ARE OF WHAT
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS ARE
ACTUALLY DOING PERFORMANCE WISE
AND SO SOME COUNTIES MIGHT HAVE
LOWER RETURN TO PRISON RATES
BECAUSE OF OTHER FACTORS SOME
COUNTIES MAY HAVE HIGHER RETURN
TO PRISON RATES BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN MORE AGGRESSIVE IN KIND OF
PROSECUTING INDIVIDUALS. AND SO
IT'S JUST REALLY THE KIND OF
STUFF STYLE WHAT IS A PROBATION
DEPARTMENT DOING VERSUS YOU.
KNOW KIND OF THESE OTHER
FACTORS. MMHM OKAY- BUT DOES
THAT DO YOU HAVE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION THAT HAS TO DO WITH
BY ASKING FOR A THREE YEAR
EXTENSION VERSES ON A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION IF WE'RE IF WE'RE UP
IN THE AIR ABOUT THE ACTUAL
INFORMATION HOW DOES THAT LEAD
O THREE YEARS INSTEAD OF ONE
YEAR FOR ITS PART THE THREE OR
FIVE THE REASON IF WE KIND OF
CAME UP WITH THAT IS OBVIOUSLY
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE DATE IS
STILL SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
MORE KIND OF DIRECTED IMMEDIATE
KOBE RESPONSES A LITTLE BIT OF A
HAS LINGERED INTO TWENTY TWENTY
TWO ALTHOUGH. THANKFULLY THINGS
DO SEEM TO BE OPENING UP ONE OF
THE CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE
WANTED TO. KIND OF TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO DATA WITH IT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME KIND OF COURT IMPACTS AS
FAR AS BACKLOGS FOR CASES THAT
HAVE KIND OF BEEN- DELAYED AND
DISPOSITIONS I DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC BY COUNTY DATA FOR THIS
BUT WE HAVE HEARD KIND OF
ANECDOTALLY THAT HAVE. BEEN
SENDING REDUCE DISPOSITIONS
PARTICULAR ON THEIR FELONY
CASELOADS I'M JUST BECAUSE OF
KIND OF GENERAL IMPACTS AND A
POTENTIAL BACKLOG- IN SO TO THE
EXTENT WE THOUGHT THAT THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO DATE WOULD CAN
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE KIND
OF NOISY OR KIND OF EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT AND THEN THE REASON FOR THE
THIRD YEARS IS LARGELY BASED ON
THE KIND OF YEAR TO YEAR
COMPARISON AT THE EXISTING
FORMULA CONSIDERS. SO WE WANTED
TO KIND OF HAVE A SPACE BETWEEN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE ONE THING'S KIND OF
OUR ARE ANTICIPATED AND
HOPEFULLY NORMALIZED IT THERE
WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL YEAR TO
BECAUSE ONCE THINGS DO NORMALIZE
IF THERE HAD BEEN LIKE A
REDUCING INDIA WILL SENT. BACK
TO PRISON FROM THE FELONY
SUPERVISION CASELOADS THE BEST
SUBSEQUENT YEAR WHEN THINGS DID
FINALLY NORMALIZED IF THERE'D BE
ANY YOU KNOW ANY ALLOCATED-
FIGURE ASSOCIATED WITH IT AND SO
WE KIND OF WANTEDTO BUILD IN A
LITTLE BIT OF A APPLICATION TO
REFLECT BACK TO. THE FORMULA
KIND OF NORMALIZE IT WOULD GET
BACK TO THAT YEAR TO YEAR
COMPARISON. ASKED INTENDED. AT
OKAY. I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I
THE THREE YEARS LITTLE. IS TO
CHEN CONSIDERING THE AND- THAT
WERE LACKING ON THIS. OF THANK
YOU VERY APPRECIATE THAT
PRESENTATION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE SIX. WHICH IS THE
ADULT RE ENTRY OUR PROGRAM AND
WILL HAVE THE- DSCC- MAKE A
PRESENTATION. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SIDE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
RECORDED THE GREAT SHIP THE
BOARD'S THINKING CORRECTIONS.
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OVERVIEW YOU DON'T RICH PROGRAM. WE ARE NOT RICHARD GRANT
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT AND
HAS ECEIVED ONGOING FIND IN
EACH YEAR THEREAFTER. THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
DELIVER REENTRY SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE FROM INCARCERATED STATE
PRISON. SPECIFICALLY FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE- ONE HAND OFTEN
REENTRY SERVICES AND
REHABILITATION OF EXISTING
PROPERTIES AND BUILDINGS. NOW
THE ENERGY PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
FUNDING TO COURTS AND A THIRD
COURT IS FUNDED DEVELOPMENT.
WHAT ONE HAS ALLOCATED
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY MILLION
BETWEEN SEVENTY PROGRAMS AND A
QUICK BREAKDOWN OF THAT IS
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE MILLION
IS GOING TOWARDS SIXTY NINE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROVIDING.
RENTAL ASSISTANCE SOME WARM HAND
OFF RANGE- SERVICES. FIVE
MILLION IS GOING TO ONE PROJECT
FOR THE REHABILITATION OF AN
EXISTING PROPERTY AND- YOU HEARD
FROM A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
ABBEY FOUNDATION AND IN THIS
INSTANCE- THEY ARE ONE OF THEY
ARE THE AGENCIES RECEIVE BETTER-
THAT FILING THE APPLICATION- FOR
COURT TO- WE'VE ALLOCATED A
POSSIBLY THIRTY FIVE MILLION-
BETWEEN FORTY FIVE PROGRAMS-
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
TOWARDS EIGHT PROGRAMS PROVIDING
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. AND ANOTHER
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE TOWARDS
THIRTY SEVEN PROGRAMS PROVIDING
WARM HAND. OFF THE SERVICES- IS
YOU MY IMAGINE- THESE FINE ARE
ARE TO PROVIDE KEY SO. I COMPLY
ALL THEM BUT JUST SOME THEM AND
- CASE MAN. HOUSING NAVIGATION-
PERMITS SPORTED HOUSING RENTAL
SUBSIDY SUBSIDIES ARE SHORT TERM
EMERGENCY HOUSING- TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING HOUSING VOUCHERS- AND
JUST SOMEONE AND SO FORTH- I
WOULD SURE THAT SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED THROUGH ALL CALIFORNIA-
FROM PROVIDERS LOCATED AS FAR
NORTH AS PLUMAS COUNTY- ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN. AND I'M
FINALLY I'LL JUST CLOSE WITH WE
HAVE A COMPETITIVE COWORK THREE
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL THAT'S-
I'LL RIGHT NOW AREN'T SENATE'S
CONCLUDE RIGHT NOW FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND WARM HAND OFF
REENTRY SERVICES PROJECT- THAT
WAS RELEASED BACK ON FEBRUARY
ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO- A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE TWENTY
BASED. ORGANIZATIONS REQUESTED
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION- FOR THE
SIXTY THREE MILLION THAT WAS
AVAILABLE BETWEEN THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND WARM HAND OFF.
RICHIE SERVICES PAPA- THAT SAID
- PROPOSAL SELECTED FOR FUNDING
WILL BE KILEY. FOR OCT OF THIS
YEAR APRIL THIRTY TWO TWENTY.
AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE PSC
BOARD- WILL MAKE A FINAL
DECISION AS SOON AS SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SOFTBALL PAS
THERE FOR NOW AND TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU ON
SENATOR NEWMAN ANY. ALLEN'S
CLASS AS YOU CHRISTIAN BUT MY
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
FUNDING IS COMING. IN THE FORM
OF ONE TIME GRANTS IN EACH
SUCCESSIVE BUDGET YEARS ARE
CORRECT. THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THIS IS
DEREK. IT IS AN ONGOING FUNDING
PROGRAM- IT'S BEEN SUPPLEMENTED
WITH- INCREASE FUNDING AND AN
ESCALATING YEARS IN THE BUDGET
IN THE PAST SUCH ACTS OKAY ALL
RIGHT PRECIADO SAID DAD THAT'S
APPROACHING THANK AND WHAT IS
THAT ONGOING FUNDING REMIND
REMIND US AGAIN- WELL IT'S IN-
THAT SO LET'S SEE THE INITIAL
ALLOCATION WAS. A FIFTY MILLION
- AND IN RECENT YEARS IT SPENT
THIRTY SEVEN BILLION. AND THEN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED A ONE TIME INCREASE
THAT PROVIDED SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION. SIXTY SEVEN BEING THE
TOTAL. CORRECT SPLIT BETWEEN OUR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND WARM AND
OFFERING. TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT
WAS SIXTY SEVEN MILLION NOBODY
BUT MY NOTES SHOW THAT THAT.
ONGOING OF THAT THIRTY SEVEN IS
NOT GOING TO THIRTY. THIRTY IS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATIONS ARE CORRECT SO THE
THIRTY SEVEN MINUS THE ON GOING
FUNDING. UNDERSTOOD SO WELL SO
WHAT'S THE RIGHT NUMBER BOB
DONNAN ONGOING BASIS IF YOU KNOW
IF WE ARE EACH YEAR. ADDING ONE
TIME FUNDS HAD SIMPLY HAVE TO
MEET THAT THAT'S- YOU KNOW DE
FACTO THE ONGOING NEED. YET
PARTS OF THIRTY SEVEN MINUS THE
REGULAR OF IT BUT I'M GOING
FUNDING CORRECT. NO THAT'S OTHER
QUESTIONS IS WHAT LIKE WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY AS WE LOOK FOR.
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE ONGOING
NEED SO YOUKNOW WE WERE VERY
FORTUNATE A SURPLUS RIGHT NOW WE
WON'T HAVE IT FOREVER. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT MAKE SURE THAT WOULD
THAT THESE THINGS DON'T. SUFFER
AS A RESULT OF CHANGES IN OUR
FISCAL POSITION OF THE REALLY
IMPORTANT IF THEY IF THEY YIELD
RESULTS. SURE MY APOLOGIES FOR
MISUNDERSTANDING A QUESTION THIS
WEEK- IT'S DIFFICULT TO SEE WHAT
THE RIGHT NUMBER IS IF I JUST
FOR EXAMPLE THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENED RECENTLY- ARE OUR MOST
RECENT SOLICITATION LIKE I SAID
WE RECEIVED. A REQUEST FOR IN
EXCESS OF A HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION- IN TWENTY NINETEEN
RECEIVED REQUESTS IN EXCESS OF A
HUNDRED NINE MILLION. SO THE
NUMBERS ARE A LITTLE BIT HARDER
TO POINT DOWN- BUT THAT THEY'RE
SO MANY IT YOU KNOW IS IN NEED
AND WE AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE
ALLOCATE NOT AS MUCH FUN AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. READ AND I GUESS
THAT YOU KNOW THE BEST MOST
OBVIOUS METRIC FOR SUCCESS IS
RECIDIVISM. THE END I GUESS
THAT'S WHERE RECIDIVISM MAY COME
AT RIGHT THERE'S A COUPLE OF.
THOSE SINCE YOU KNOW THEIR
TESTIMONY THIS COUPLE AREAS
WHERE DATA ANALYSIS PROBABLY.
NECESSARY VERY USEFUL TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S THE BEST USE OF
FUNDS- I THINK INTUITIVELY KNOW
THAT THESE YOU KNOW THAT THE
ADULT REENTRY PROGRAMS FAR.
EMILY EFFECTIVE BUT DID IT BE
REALLY HELPFUL TO HAVE THAT BY
WAY OF DATA SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS AS TO HOW WE
ALLOCATE FUNDS. SHOULD THANK YOU
APPRECIATE JUST WANT THINGS.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE DONE- OKAY
JUST ONE QUESTION HOW MUCH OF
FUNDING HAS GONE TOWARDS
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
VERSES TRANSITIONAL OR EMERGENCY
HOUSING. CAN YOU BREAK DOWN A
BIT I DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER
READILY AVAILABLE WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY PROVIDED TO YOU OKAY.
PLEASE BECAUSE YOU ARE FOCUSED
ON HOUSING RIGHT THAT IS ALL
ABSOLUTELY YEAH WE HAVE. THE
GENERIC RENTAL ASSISTANCE-
COMPLAINING THAT THIS PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING BUT FOR THAT
THAT MORE DETAILED BREAKDOWN
WOULD HAVE TO JUST. PUT THE
NUMBERS TOGETHER JUST A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL. GREAT OKAY IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE THAT THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL- I THINK
THAT'S IT SENATORS NOTHING ELSE
. DR BRECHER WE DONE HERE. YES
WE'RE DONE HERE FOR THE- WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS
THAT- WERE PRESENTED TODAY ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THE IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN THE NUMBERS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO- WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT.
EVERYONE PARTICIPATING IN PUBLIC
COMMENT KEEP YOUR MARKS TO
WITHIN ABOUT A MINUTE AND WE ARE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
HERE IN PERSON IN THE HEARING
ROOM- IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO.
TESTIFY GIVE SOME TESTIMONY
PLEASE COME RIGHT UP. I SEE THAT
THERE IS AT LEAST ONE. PERSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU I CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HAD ONLY ONE
UNITED I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN- AND ALL OF US OR
NONE- AS WELL AS REPRESENTING
THE COALITION FOR FAMILY UNITY
I'M VERY HONORED TO BE HERE- AND
REALLY JUST HERE TO ADVOCATE
FOR- THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
THIRD DAY VISITING- AND NOTING
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE AN PERCENT-
AS- GOOD AS A DIGITAL.
COMMUNICATION CAN BE- THERE'S
NOTHING THAT CAN REPLACE YOU
KNOW THE PHYSICAL ATTRACTION- IN
PERSON VISITING- AND YOU KNOW
HAVING A LOT OF FAMILY. THAT'S
INSIDE BEING SOMEBODY THAT'S
EXPERIENCE ACCULTURATION MYSELF-
IT'S REALLY A LIFELINE THAT YOU
KNOW- IF THAT IS THE NECESSARY-
KNIFE LIFELINE THAT REALLY HELPS
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO. MANAGE HEN
SURVIVE YOU KNOW WHETHER INSIDE-
AND GIVES US A LOT OF HOPE- AND
YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO. HAVE
SOMETHING TO STRIVE FOR MORE
ABLE TO KEEP THAT CONNECTION
WITH THEIR CHILDREN WITH THEIR
PARENTS WITH THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS. I'M REALLY MOTIVATES US
TO. I WANT TO DO BETTER AND TO-
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY SEE THE DAY
WHEN WE CAN GET OUR AND- YOU
KNOW- START YOU KNOW. REALLY
EXPANDING ON THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEIR CHILDREN OR FAMILY
MEMBERS- AS WELL AS- A FROM
MEMBERS OURSELVESTHAT THEY'RE
NOT. YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT HAVE
COMMITTED ANY CRIME TRACK SO
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS ARE PEOPLE
THAT. I DESERVE THE RIGHT TO-
SEE THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS WHETHER
THEY'RE INCARCERATED OR NOT- WE
BELIEVE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
IT'S A HUMAN RIGHT- AND ALSO. I
JUST WANT ADVOCATE FOR PHONE
CALLS- TO BE FREE AS WELL AND-
EARLIER- COMMITTEE MEMBER
MENTIONED HEALTH- JUST. REALLY
HOW RIDICULOUS IS THAT WE'RE
STILL KIND OF RATIONING MINUTES
AND STUFF IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO- I THINK
THAT ARE. YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
AT HIGH TIME TO REALLY START A
PROVIDING SOME OF THESE BASIC-
YOU KNOW NECESSITIES FOR FREE. I
THINK THAT WE HAVE A CAT AND WE
SHOULD- AND LASTLY-
TRANSPORTATION YOU KNOW WE CAN
IMPLEMENT HIS MANY DAYS AS WE
WOULD LIKE BUT IF WE DON'T
PROVIDE THAT TRANSPORTATION
SUPPORT. FOR FAMILIES WHEN I CAN
BE ABLE TO FULFILL- THOSE
VISITATION SO- I HAVE FAMILY
THAT IS. LOCKED UP ALL THE WAY
IN LIKE LIFE YOU KNOW IRON
WOULD- IT'S A REALLY LONG WAYS
AND SO- FOR FAMILY MEMBERS TO BE
ABLE TO TRAVEL AND- ACCOMMODATE
THOSE. EXPENSES I THINK WOULD BE
I'M. DEFINITELY IDEAL AND SO-
LIKE I SAID WE HERE TO AT THE
FOR THOSE PIECE. I THINK THAT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S THE SAME WAY
WHEN- IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET- AND
I'LL- THE MY TOWARDS THE THINGS
SO- I WOULD. HOPE THAT- CITIES
CAN BEGIN TO ON- THE BUDGET
REQUEST- AND BEGINS TO- REUNITE
THE FAMILIES AND- IMPLEMENTED
THURSDAY VISITING SUPPORT FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND HOPEFULLY
PROVIDE FREE PHONE CALLS AS
WELL. THANK YOU THANK YOU COULD
YOU SAY YOUR NAME AGAIN YEAH I
HAD ON THE MARKET NOT. A KILLER
POLICY ANALYST WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. YOUR
TESTIMONY IN PERSON IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT. WE CAN ALL
CONTINUE TO WORK HARD ON THE
ISSUES THAT YOU'VE RAISED THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER YOUR TAKE
CARE. YES WHAT IS THE YOUR
ADDRESS SO MANY SIMILAR KEY
SOMEONE FOR MILLING CARCERI. A
MAN WHO SPENT EIGHTEEN YEARS
HALF OF MY LIFE IN PRISON. FOR A
CALL FROM DIRECT EXPERIENCE SOME
ALSO- THAT- CHAPTER ORGANIZER-
FOR ALL OF US IN NINE LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WHO
CHILDREN. CO FOUNDER OF
SOFTWARES TO RECOVER THEIR
STARTING IN PRISON IN OPERATION
SELL SACRAMENTO. INDEPENDENTLY
AND ALSO TIME BOUND DELEGATES
THE CHAPTER LEAD IN A N A
FOUNDER OF COMMUNITY HE LIVES-
VISITING IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
OUR FAMILY SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO
SPEAK ON FAMILIES. ON THE
MOTHERS ON THE SISTERS IS ON ON
THE WIVES STAY CONSTANTLY
OVERWHELM OUR OFFICES FOR
SUPPORT. AMONG SOME JUSTICES IN
THIS COMMUNITY MUST THE ABUSE
THE GOALS IN THESE INSTITUTIONS
I GET CALLS. HI I GAVE I GAVE
TEXAS A MESSAGES FROM THE NEW.
DIGITAL MEDIA THAT WE PUSH TO
GET FOR PEOPLE TO COMMUNICATE.
AND THAT MEDIA IS OUTDATED THAT
THE ALLIED MEDIA IS BASICALLY
TAKING ADVANTAGE ARE OUR PEOPLE.
WE WISH TO WE SPEND WAY TOO MUCH
FOR STUFF BY THE FULL IT DID THE
COST DROP- YOU KNOW THERE'S A
BUNCH UP AGAIN WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY. SO WE SUPPORT IN
THAT CAPACITY SO WE NEED THAT
THIRD DAY ARE. WHEN I WAS IN A
WE HAVE FOUR DAYS WE HAD FRIDAY
THURSDAY SATURDAY SUNDAY. I WAS
ENGAGED AT THE TIME YOU KNOW I
YOU KNOW I SPENT MY YOUNG LIFE
INNER SIDE- YOU KNOW HAVING
THOSE THIS IS WITH MY FAMILY
EVERY THREE MONTHS YOU KNOW EVEN
KNOWS THE DISTANCE. IT HELP ME
STAY ROOTED IS TO HELP ME GROW
AND HELP ME HAVE MOTIVATION TO
CHANGE A AND HUMAN ADDRESS THE
THINGS THAT LED ME TO PRISON.
AND I SPEND A LOT OF HOURS IN
YEARS WITH A LOT OF THE MAN WHO
WENT TO SOME OF. THE REFER
CHILDHOOD. AND I NEVER GOT
ADDRESS WHEN HE GOT CONVICTED
BUT YET THEY WANTED TO BE
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND UNDERSTANDING
THE FACTORS BEFORE LEAVING HE
CONSIDER FOR BOARD. SO YOU KNOW
WE WHAT WE NEED DEFICIT BECAUSE-
THAT CONNECTED THERE'S A
DIMINISH THE STRESS ISSUES WITH
REJECTION ISSUES THEY'LL TURN
INTO. A SOCIAL BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
EMOTIONAL HEALTH PROBLEMS. BUT.
SOMETIMES BECAUSE OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO BE OUT HERE WITHOUT
GUYS. AND IN THE BEGINNING SO TO
THE SYSTEM CIRCUMSTANCES OF
SURVIVE INTEREST. SO THAT'S WITH
THE- AND THE PRESSURE- TO HOLD
THE DEPARTMENT TO QUICKLY GAMES
I ALSO. IN THE VISOR COUNCIL.
AND YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN WE- ALEX
MY THIRD DAY. YOU'LL BE SIGNED
THE GAMES THEY PLAY. AND WE'RE
HERE WITH THE- TO STAND YOU
KNOW. WITH OUR- AND OUR
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS TO SAY
THAT EIGHT. ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
JUST QUIT PLAYING GAMES THIS
ADDRESSIT IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT WE NEED TO DO ON OUR END.
AS COMMUNITY ORGANIZERS THAT
ADDITIONAL AND WE WILL DO OUR
PART THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR COMING. TAKING THE TIME
TO BE HERE YOU SEE VERY MUCH. UP
MODERATOR- SEEN. NO ONE ELSE
HERE IN THE ROOM IN PERSON-
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND CAN YOU TELL
ME THAT TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY. AT TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
AT THE POINT WE HAVE ELEVEN
PEOPLE IN Q. WE WILL START WE
HAVE FORT. SIXTEEN PEOPLE IN
HERE WE'LL START WITH LINE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD I JUST WANT
TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT EVERYONE
pWITHIN THE MINUTE SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHERIN
REPORT I'M WITH- NONPROFIT THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND I'M COMMENTING ON
ISSUES OF RESPECT- WE DO SEE
THAT THE ADULT REENTRY GRANT
HAVE SINCE TRANSFORMATIONAL
SOMETHING WE NEED. FURTHER
TRANSFORMATION TO ADD HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES WITHOUT LIMITS ON
LENGTH OF STAY FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE RECENT EXPERIENCE OF PRISON
AND ARE NOW HOMELESS. PERMANENT
HOUSING PROGRAM SHOULD ALSO BE
RUN BY OUR HOUSING AGENCY OUR
HOUSING DEPARTMENT HAS EXPERTISE
IN OVERSEEING EVIDENCE BASED
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND
RELATIONSHIPS WITH LOCAL
HOMELESS CONTINUES TO CARE.
OTHER STATES HAVE IMPLEMENTED
EVIDENCE BASED HOUSING PROGRAMS
THAT DO NOT LIMIT LENGTH OF STAY
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE LEASES AND
RIGHTS RESPONSIBILITY OF
TENANCY. AS ONE EXAMPLE- HIGHS
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS HAVE 61%
LESS RECIDIVISM THAN A CONTROL
GROUP. WE FURTHER RECOMMEND
INCORPORATING EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES THAT ALLOW PEOPLE TO
EARN LIVING WAGE JOBS AND TAKE
OVER VAN WITHOUT ARTIFICIAL TIME
. WE'RE WORKING WITH THE SENATE
MEMBER FOR AND SIX OTHER
SPONSORS TO PROMOTE EVERY ENTRY
HOUSING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM TO AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN AND I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS FOR CALLING. NEXT
NEXT NEXT LINE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M DARBY KERNAN I'M
REPRESENTING HEALTH RIGHT THREE
SIXTY LESS CARE AND AMITY
FOUNDATION TODAY. AND THE
SURVIVORS PROVIDE COMMUNITY
REENTRY SERVICES WITHIN
CALIFORNIA I'M COMMENTING ON
ITEM NUMBER THREE THE COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAM AS MENTIONED
EARLIER FROM THE STANFORD STUDY
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
COMMUNITY RE ENTRY FOR AT LEAST
NINE MIGHT. RESULT IN A DECREASE
AVERAGE OF ONE YEAR CONVICTION
RATE. 92% ELEVEN OVERALL
PERCENTAGE POINT THAT IS A HUGE
TRANSFORMATION BY GIVING
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY UPON
THEIR RELEASE FROM PRISON AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN RE ENTRY
PROGRAMS TO ADJUST TO THE WORLD.
ONLY MAKES THE PUBLIC SAFER AND
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
RETURNING TO PRESENT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR STAYING ON TOP. THE NEXT. I
AM EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
REYES CALLING ON BEHALF OF
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON AND THE HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS AND ENSURING
EVERYONE HAS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
I'M CALLING IN REGARDS TO ISSUE
SIX. WE APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
TODAY AND ALL THE WORK HAPPENING
BUT WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LACK OF INVESTMENT IN
REENTRY HEALTHY RESOURCES THAT
FOCUS ON PERMANENT HOUSING WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE RESOURCES
SHOULD BE TEN MINISTRY BY OUR
HOUSING AGENCY RATHER THAN A
PRISON SYSTEM. FOLLOW THE
HOUSING FIRST MODEL AND MAKE
SURE PEOPLE ARE SUPPORTED BEYOND
THE TERM OF THEIR KROLL WHICH IS
WHEN MANY PEOPLE AT THAT
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING IS A
HOMELESSNESS WE BELIEVE AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN A CRIME PROPOSAL AN
ASSEMBLY PROVIDES A GOOD. MODEL
NO YOU'RE CORRECT. ATION OF THE
APPROACHING THE BUDGET. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LAKE
THANK FOUR PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHN DUGGAR ON BEHALF
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA SPEAKING TO ISSUE
FIVE THE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES ON
PROBATION CHIEFS ARE COMMITTED
TO THE CORE GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM
TO REDUCE PRISON ADMISSION
THROUGH EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
AND ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ONGOING NEED FOR A PERFORMANCE
STATE METHODOLOGY. THE LEFT ME
THAT SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT REDUCE
PRISON REPLICATION I'M MORE THAN
30% IN JUST TWO YEARS HAVE STATE
TO STAY OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS
HOWEVER GIVEN THE DYNAMIC NATURE
OF STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
PROGRAMS IN COURT PROCESSING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THE
DAILY NEWS FOR THE CALCULATION
DOES NOT. REFLECT LOCAL
PRACTICES AND PERFORMANCE FOR
THE NEXT FEW YEARS OF THE GRANT
CALCULATION THEREFORE HE POCKETS
SUPPORTIVE OF AN EXTENSION OF
THE CURRENT YEAR METHODOLOGY
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL UPON
SYSTEM AND DATA STABILISATION
ONGOING CHANGES MAY ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO SUSTAIN A PROGRAM
THAT IS BOTH PERFORMANCE SPACE
AND RECOGNIZES THE PAST EXPECTED
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. BUT BUILT
A FOUNDATION FOR LANDMARK
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS IN
CALIFORNIA THESE REFORMS
SOLIDIFIED THE STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY CONTINUE ON AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER PARTNERING ON
THIS VITAL PROGRAM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE MY NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM MEMBER CHRIS RESPONSE AS
FAR ADVOCATE WITH THE WEST
CENTER LAMPARD CON IS A PART OF
ISSUE ONE WANTED THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ASKING FOR QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PHONE CALLS IN THE
MEDIA COMMUNICATION AGREE WITH
YOU THAT'S PART OF THE FAMILY
CONTINUE TO BEAR A PER MINUTE
COSTS FOR AN UPDATED SYSTEM
LEADERS ARE COMMITTED TO MAKE
ALL FORMS OF COMMUNICATION FREE
TO KEEP FAMILIES CONNECTED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE. MY NAME
SIX PLEASE GO. HE TO MENTOR
CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF OF MARK
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA ON ITEM NUMBER THREE
MARKET THE CALIFORNIA AND THE
PROSECUTORS LINES CALIFORNIA
ORANGE STRONG SUPPORT OF
EXPANDING THE USE OF
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING WHEN PEOPLE
ARE LEADING CITIES YOUR CUSTODY
BUT THERE'S NOT MANY PLACES
WHERE WE ACTUALLY THINK THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING A
BETTER JOB IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THIS IS ONE. IT MAKES SENSE THAT
WE SHOULDN'T BE BUT PEOPLE WALK
OUT OF PRISON ON TO THE STREET
THAT WE SHOULD USE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
PREPARED THAT IS GOOD FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. I'M TRYING PLEASE
GOD. TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD. YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS
MARVIN DAMAGE FROM LEGAL PROOF
OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN- POLICY ADVOCATE
AND- I JUST FIRST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME
AND ALSO FOR BEING VERY FAIR AND
JUST TODAY. AND THE ITEMS THAT
WERE HEARD AND I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT ONE WHICH IS ABOUT A VISIT
IN THE PRISON AND I JUST WANT TO
REALLY QUICKLY SHARE MY STORY-
WHEN I WAS INCARCERATED FOR TEN
YEARS- VISITING FOR MY MOM AND
MY GRANDMA- WERE VERY IMPORTANT.
AND WHEN I WENT TO SEE THE C. R.
EVEN THOUGH I REQUESTED A
WRITTEN REQUEST- OF POLICE TO-
STAY CLOSE TO THE BAY AREA CLOSE
MY FAMILY THEY ACTUALLY DID THE
OPPOSITE IN SEVENTY TWO BLACK
CALIFORNIA FOR ANYBODY KNOWS
WHERE THAT IS. IT'S ONLY A
COUPLE MILES FROM ARIZONA
BORDER. THE BURDEN OF MY FAMILY
TO SEE ME FOR A COUPLE HOURS TO
TRAVEL FOR THE WHOLE WEEKEND WAS
SOLD MUCH BETTER I TOLD MY
ELDERLY GRANDMOTHER WAS SICK
WITH DIABETES AND SO IS MY MOM I
TOLD DON'T COME DON'T COME TO
SEE ME. DOLE DON'T COME ANYMORE
AND- THEY DIDN'T LISTEN. THEY
STILL. TO ME THIS. THAT IT WAS A
- FOR THEM FOURTEEN. FOR ME THEY
CAN MAKE. FOR ME THE TO FIELD.
OF THE- PART OF MY FAMILY SO
THEY KEPT DOING IT. AND IT WAS
IT WAS IT WAS IT WAS A REAL
BURDEN ON THEM. AND I FEEL THAT-
THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE THANK YOU-
WE SHOULD YOUR STORY THANK YOU
FOR SHARING NEXT PLEASE. NINE
ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
HOW FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS TRACKING A LITTLE BIT
LATE LEGAL AFFAIRS OR PREGNANT
WITH CHILDREN FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
ONE LATEST TO RESPOND BECAUSE
AND WHAT ENCOURAGE THE COMMUNITY
TO MAKE OUR FORMS NOTHING. BRIEF
I LOVE WERE INTENSELY IT IS TIME
TO STOP BY THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
ON FAMILIES AND MAKE IT EASIER.
TO KEEP FAMILIES CONNECTED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR. NEXT
PLEASE. I NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES GO AHEAD IT.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JOHN AND I
HAVE ALREADY AND I- AND CALLING
WITH REFERENCE TO NUMBER ONE AND
I'M WHAT I'M FAMILIES UNITED AND
THE L. LOCK- IMPLEMENTATION OF A
THIRD DAY OF IN PERSON BIDDING
VISITING A VITAL- I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE VISITING
SCHEDULING. IT NEEDS THEM THE
RELEASE DATE LIKE IF I CAN'T
MAKE THE APPOINTMENT ON FRIDAY
OR SATURDAY OR SUNDAY. I SHOULD
BE ABLE TO RELEASE IT UP UNTIL
THE DAY OF THE APPOINTMENT OF
SOMEBODY ELSE CAN TAKE THE
APPOINTMENT AND BE ABLE TO SEE
THEIR LOVED ONES. ARE READY THEY
CLOSED ON TUESDAY. THANK HAPPEN
PEOPLE GET SICK. AND
UNFORTUNATELY OUR LOVED ONES
OUT- NOT ENOUGH CABLE- NOT
ENOUGH FOOD IN THE VALLE MACHINE
. COLDER A LOT THAT NEEDS TO BE
A- AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE
. AND WHEN I WON PLEASE GO AHEAD
. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LUCY A
MEDICAL CLINIC RESPONSIBLE
LENDING BASED IN OAKLAND BUT WE
DO OUR WORK STATEWIDE AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE
RELATED TO THE FREE PHONE CALLS
AND FREE COMMUNICATION. BUT IT
HEARD THE COMMITTED TO MAKE ALL
FORMS OF COMMUNICATION THREE FOR
A LOVED ONE KATHY. IT KIND OF
WAKING THE FINANCIAL PART OF THE
FAMILY THAT MAKE IT EASIER TO
KEEP FAMILY CONNECTED AT ALL
TIMES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE
THREE GO- WARRANTY CAN- HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU I DON'T HAVE AN
BECAUSE NEED TO FIGHT RIGHT THE
FACT THAT MY CHRYSLER PEOPLE
TAKE A LOOK AT THE END OF THE
THANK PERSONALLY HAVE MY HUSBAND
. IN CAR THREE. ONLY FOR SUPPORT
AND IF WAS MADE EASY FOR A TO
COME IN THE HIM HE HAPPENS WAY
MORE SUPPORT THERE'S A THREE TO
VERY OKAY IN. PLACE IN ONE OF A
SENIOR TO SEE A THE LEFT ONE
THING. WE ARE. THE A LOOK.
INDICATION ALL WE EDUCATE CREATE
PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT
RECIDIVISM AND ABOUT PROGRAMS
FOR PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
PERSONS. WHO ARE RETURNING HOME
THAT RESULTS FROM SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY. M. REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN MEMORY
COMMUNICATION IS ONE SUCH
PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT
PLEASE. NINETY SEVENTY ONE LINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA CASSAVA- I
AM IN L. WALKWAY AND I WANTED TO
CALL AND- I WANTED TO CALL AND
LET YOU KNOW THAT I'M IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHT THIRTY AGAIN PERSON
VISITING. IF YOUR VIDEO CALLS
ARE NOT VISIT AND ALSO I WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT I HAVE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THAT I HAVE
EMAILED TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR A BOTH CALLING AND
SENDING IN YOUR- SUGGESTIONS
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE OH TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN ATTENDED MY NAME IS RUBY
GOT THE ADS WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE AND I AM SPEAKING ON
ISSUES SEVEN I AM MARRIED TO. MY
LOVED ONE IS THAT CORPORATE
STATE PRISON AND WE HAVE BEEN
MARRIED SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
I'M NOT HAD A FAMILY VISIT
ALTHOUGH THE LAWS HAVE CHANGED
BECAUSE HE GOT CAUGHT WITH THE
PHONE- WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
HAVE A FAMILY VISIT HE GOT
CAUGHT WITH THE PHONE BECAUSE HE
WAS CALLING ME BECAUSE I WAS IN
THE HOSPITAL CO THAT. SO WITH
THAT SAID AND DONE I AM ASKING
THAT DATE AND THAT THEY CAN MAKE
VISITING EIGHT NOT A PRIVILEGE
BUT A RIGHT. LIKE I SAID WE'RE
ENTERING OUR EIGHTH YOUR
MARRIAGE AND STILL HAVE NOT HAD
ONE FAMILY VISIT IN THE EYES OF
THE LORD IF YOU. PRACTICE YOU
KNOW ANY KIND OF RELIGION WHEN
YOU DON'T CONSUMMATE A MARRIAGE
IT'S NOT CONSIDERED A MARRIAGE
AND FOR A WOMAN THAT IT'S HARD
ESPECIALLY MYSELF WAS IN TWO
VILLAGES STUDY SO I'M JUST
ASKING EXTEND BY- ISSUE SEVEN
KEEP ME AND ALSO FOR ANY. OF THE
RE ENTRY PROGRAMS THAT THE
EXPAND ON WHO THEY ARE ALLOWING
TO COME IN MY HUSBAND HAS BEEN
ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN HE WAS DENIED FOR FIVE
YEARS AND HAVE ALREADY BEEN DOWN
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS. SO I'M SURE
THAT WE NEED A REVISION WE NEED
A MAJOR OVERHAUL AND I'M ASKING
AND BELIEVING WITH THIS NEW-
EVERYTHING'S COMING TOGETHER AND
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON BOARD
THAT CHANGES THAT COME BECAUSE
WE NEED TO START. LOOKING AT
REHABILITATION AND LYFT IN CARS
REYES THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND THANK YOU THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING. YEAH
ONE HAS. MY KART I WEAK ON
CALLING WITH- PART OF JEFF UP
THE PLACE OF ENERGY AND I AM
CALL IN SUPPORT OF THE THIRD DAY
OF PERSON VISITS I THINK VIDEO
CALL AREN'T VISIT. FROM HAVE
BEEN BRILLIANT. AT L. A. C. I
DID NOT WOULD NOT TO GET RESERVE
UNTIL THE FOURTH MONTH MONTH
WHICH WAS LAST WEEK. OR MONTH
EXACTLY TO DATE WITH FINALLY- I
WAS ABLE TO SEE MY HUSBAND NOW
NOT TO MENTION LIKE THE ISSUE
THAT TECHNICAL ISSUE THAT-
HAPPEN WITH THE ESTATE I WOULD
ALSO- TURNED AWAY WHILE I WAS
THERE I VISIT. BECAUSE THE AT
THE ACCORDING TO L. A. C. WAS
THAT THEY OVER BOOKED
APPOINTMENTS SO I'M A STRONG
SUPPORT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
MENTION THAT CAL STATE DOES NOT
HAVE AN IFC. AND THEY DO NOT
HAVE BEEN- FAMILY VISIT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FOR CALLING NEXT
PLEASE. I AM SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M GETTING MY A
LITTLE BIT BETTER SORRY ABOUT
THAT MY NAME IS SANDRA WHAT IS
AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AND FOUNDER OF TEXAS BASED
ORGANIZATION. I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTY VISITS AND FREE PHONE
CALLS AND COMMUNICATION TO KEEP
FAMILIES CONNECTED SB TEN ZERO
EIGHT IS CURRENTLY MOVING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATION TO GIVE
US FAMILIES. WE OF THEIR-
ONGOING FINANCIAL BURDENS THAT
WE CARRY MY DAUGHTER IS THE ONLY
IS THREE YEARS OLD AND HAVE NOT
SEEN YOUR FATHER FOR ONE AND A
HALF MONTHS I WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW WHICH- THE OTHER PERSON
THAT ALSO BUT- CALIFORNIA CITY
DOES NOT HAVE FAMILY VISITS. AND
CDCR STATED THAT- INMATE FAMILY
COUNCIL STATEWIDE BUT THERE'S
NOT CALIFORNIA CITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY DOES NOT HAVE. A FAMILY
COUNCIL SO WE- DO NOT HAVE THAT
LIKE ALL THE OTHER PRISONS TWO
AND WE DRIVE OVER TWO HOURS FOR
A TWO HOUR VISIT IF THAT
DEPENDING ON THE PROCESS TIME IF
WE GET PROCESS ON TIME THEN WE
GET TO SEE HIM FOR TWO HOURS IF
WE DON'T GIVE PROCESS ON TIME.
WE SEE HIM FOR ONE HOUR ONE AND
A HALF HOURS NOW SHE'S THREE
YEARS OLD SHE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
PAY FOR- NOT BEING ABLE TO SEE
HER FATHER HIT HER FATHER'S
MISTAKES ARE NOT MY DAUGHTER'S
MISTAKES. AND NOW- IN THIS
PRISON AGAIN THEY DON'T HAVE
FAMILY VISITS SO HE DOESN'T GET
TO SPEND THAT EXTRA QUALITY TIME
I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
THE VOICE FOR US FAMILIES WHO DO
NOT HAVE IN THE FAMILY COUNCIL
AND WHO DO NOT HAVE FAMILY
VISITS. THERE'S OVER THIRTY
PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA- THIRTY
PRISONS HAVE FAMILY VISITS AND
THIS ONE AND YOU KNOW AND YOU
KNOW PRESENT DOES NOT SO AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO A
FAMILIES- AND THEY- CAN GROW.
ZERO EIGHT THREE YEAH THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. NEXT LINE. LINE
NINETY. BUT FOR HEAD. HI THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ANNA RACK AND I
AM EVEN AND ORGANIZER WITHIN
JUSTICE AND BURKE I WANTED TO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE OR RECOGNIZING THESE
ISSUES THROUGHOUT THE HEARING
BUT I WANTED TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR TOO AGAIN THE ITEMS
ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE. I DO I AM
IN SUPPORT OF A THIRTY DAY AGAIN
PRETTY GETTING ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT YOUR CALLS ARE NOT DATED
I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT OF A NEW
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR VISITORS
I HAVE TWO BROTHERS CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED YOU HAVE BEEN THERE
YOU AND I'M APPROVED TO VISIT
ONE BUT MY APPLICATION HAD BEEN
DENIED FOR VISITING THE OTHER
OUT WITH NO REAL DIRECTION AS TO
HOW TO GET STAFF. APPROVED AND I
ALSO WANT TO ADD THAT YOU NEED
TO BE VERY RECALLS AS WELL
BECAUSE MY FAMILY HAD REPORTED
BOTH OF MY BROTHERS INCARCERATED
FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS IN
CARRYING THAT FINANCIAL BURDEN
WITH A SPORT BAND WE SEVEN
ALREADY- IS EXTREME AND THEN NOT
EMISSIONS THAT PROFIT THAT
VISITING FOR THE FIVE OF US ARE
FREE- AND WHAT THAT PROFITED BY
HAVING ONLY LIMITED VISITING
DAYS. AND THINK THAT THAT NATURE
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR EXTEND THE ITEM FOR
YOU I AND NUMBER THREE I'M AND
IF YOU COULD PLEASE WRAP UP I
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. PLEASE
WRAP UP AT. EIGHT I YOU YEAH I
DID ITEM NUMBER. ETHNICALLY
DEVELOP PROGRAMS TO MARK. HI MY
COMMUNITY DON'T HAVE ANY. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR. NEXT
PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT PLEASE. NINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. HI THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION- I'M
CALLING WITH REGARDS TO ISSUE
THREE- WE BELIEVE THAT-
CONNECTING PEOPLE WHO ARE
LEAVING PRISONS TO- SUPPORTED
PROGRAM IN THEIR COMMUNITY- IS
THE MAIN. AND WILL RESULT- AND
LET'S RESET OF ISLAM WHICH IS
PUBLIC SAFETY. WELL OVER THE
LONG RUN REDUCE COSTS- FOR CDC
ARE- I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
BRIEFLY- VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
FAMILY MEMBERS. OF THE
INCARCERATED AND- WE NEED TO GET
THE THURSDAY- IN PERSON VISIT.
PRISONS THE FTC AREN'T PROBLEMS-
PROCURING THE BOXES- PERHAPS WE
SHOULD GET FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE
INCARCERATED ABOUT CHURCH OR.
I'M SURE IF WE PUT OUR HEADS
TOGETHER- WE CAN WORK IT OUT
BUT- THERE HAS TO BE ABLE. BUT
ALSO TO- EXPRESS MY SCHOOL
SUPPORT- FOR FREE PHONE CALL THE
ECONOMIC TRAINS AND ON THE
FAMILY. AND COMMUNITIES IT IT
COOL HI THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT PLEASE. I AM WHEN A
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YOU
YOU MAY LET YOUR WITH GREAT AND
CHILD POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE
AND REALLY WANTED TO EXPRESS
THANK YOU TO OUR- SENATE FOR
INCLUDING FREE PHONE CALLS IN
THE SENATE BUDGET FIND INTO
TWENTY PEOPLE REITERATE ALSO FOR
THAT BE EXPANDED ON TO JAIL
THAT'S WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND HAVE A GREAT DAY. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE. BY MY
NANA. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
GO AHEAD YES FINALLY YES MY NAME
IS THE ARTILLERY BISHOP AND I'M
SUPPORT OF- ITEM NUMBER ONE AND
HAVING THIRTY DAYS OF THE
PATIENT AND ALSO IN SUPPORT OF-
DURING FAMILY VISITS FOR
INCARCERATED LOVED ONES WHO HAVE
DISCIPLINE ACTIONS THAT ARE NOT
RELATED TO VISITING MY HUSBAND
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED AND I
TRAVEL FOR HOURS ONE WAY JUST TO
SEE HIM FOR TWO HOURS- ARE
PRESENT IS CURRENTLY STILL
OPERATING JUST TWO DAYS A WEEK
ONE BEING A FRIDAY SO MY
VISITING IS LIMITED TO JUST
WEEKEND. BY WORK. AND I FEEL
LIKE THEY DID FOR OVER- IT WOULD
ALLOW. TO BE BETTER IN CONTACT
WITH ONE ANOTHER I'M ALL WEALTHY
SUBMITTING COMMENT OF THE EMAIL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY-
DARLING SHEAR IN AND FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT-
MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR-
FOR YOUR WORK ON THESE ON THESE
ISSUES I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
NUMBER ONE **** EDUCATION IN
REMOTE COMMUNICATION I THINK
THAT IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
THAT FREE PHONE CALLS AND
COMMUNICATIONS BE. GIVEN TO OUR-
TO PEOPLE- INCARCERATED IT IS IN
HUGE BURDEN ON FAMILIES WHO HAVE
A LOVED ONE INCARCERATED AND IT
AND APOSS A LOT OF MONEY- WE DO
NOT- WE DO NOT. BURDEN ON ANYONE
ELSE OTHER THAN INCARCERATED
PEOPLE TO CARRY THE BURDEN OF
THEIR- LEFT TWENTY IN PRISON.
AND I THINK THAT THEY SHOULD BE
FREE. I'D SAY THANK YOU VERY
FOR. STARTED WELL THANK YOU IT
TAKE CARE NEXT PLEASE. AND WHEN
YOU CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NANCY
ROCHA AND I AM WITH THE
COLLATION COALITION FOR FAMILY
UNITY AND I ALSO HAVE A ONE WHO
IS CURRENTLY INCARCERATED FOR
THE PAST EIGHT YEARS I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF- MENTAL
HEALTH- PUBLIC SAFETY AND REAL
OF REHABILITATION FOR THE
INCARCERATED. I'M AWFUL IN
SUPPORT OF THE THIRD DAY IN
PERSON VISIT CURRENTLY THERE'S
ONLY TWO DAYS OF IN PERSON
VISITS I WANTED THE VIDEO THAT
THAT WHICH IS NOT CONSIDERED AN
IN PERSON VISIT- UNFORTUNATELY
THIRTY TO FORTY FIFTEEN MINUTE
VIDEO CALLED- NOT CONSIDERED
VISIT- I ALSO WANT TO STATE THAT
MY LOVED ONE HAS BEEN IN PRISON
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND FOR
THE PAST EIGHT YEARS HE HAS BEEN
IN AND OUT OF THE MEDICAL
FACILITIES ACROSS THE FOUR
PRESENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
FOR EVERY TIME THAT HE WOULD GO
TO A HOSPITAL IT WOULD PROLONG
THE VISIT PROCESS WE WOULD HAVE
TO START ALL OVER FROM SCRATCH.
HE HAS- CHILDREN THAT MISS HIM
AND WANT TO SEE HIM MORE OFTEN
AND THE LAST. THIS LAST. WHERE
HE WAS TRANSFERRED TO A LOWER
LEVEL PRISON WHICH MEANS- FOR
GOOD BEHAVIOR HE GETS A
SINCE DECEMBER SEVENTH WE HAVE
NOT VISITED HIM WE HAVE NOT SEEN
HIM BECAUSE EVERY TIME HE GOES
TO THE HOSPITAL HE SPENDS ABOUT
FOUR TO FIVE MONTHS THERE AND
THEY PROLONG THE PROCESS. WHICH
AFFECT MY HUSBAND'S MENTAL
HEALTH AND THE FAMILY. AND THANK
YOU FOR CALLING REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT
PLEASE AND MODERATE HOW MANY
MORE. CALLS IN THE QUEUE. THE
LAST TIME WE HAVE BEEN Q. NINE
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL EDUARDO-
RIGHT OFF THE BAT THE PLATE-
HOLDEN SUPPORT AT THIRTY TO GET
I'M ESSENTIALLY IN A THREE YEAR
THE DATE AND IT IS- CRITICS THAT
HE AS MUCH TIME AS HE CAN WITH
THE FALL- IF. FOR THE BOTH OF
THEM- CALLING THE PORT OF FREAK
. A IN FOR. EXPECTED I'M ALSO
FOUGHT FIFTY. BECAUSE. EIGHT
FOR. MY JEFF THIS NOTED FOR
FUTURE CHANGE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR MUCH FOR CALLING
MODERATE. THAT. WE HAVE NO HOUSE
AND KEITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MOM FOR YOUR- I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE AND OF MEMBER NO
MORE COMMENTS BECAUSE-
DISTRIBUTED TO THOSE WHO HAS BY
PHONE BUT ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
AND PER THANK YOU YOU HAVE YOUR
BOY ARE IN. I DON'T WANT TO SURE
THAT THERE. FOR THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY OR IF
YOU DID YOU CAN STILL SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO US I WANT
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR BACK BILL-
ALL OF OUR- OF THE STAFF HERE
THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WE ARE JOINED. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN.